Hello,
everybody.
Hello, hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
Howdy, do you welcome me?
I got my crowbar.
I got my glasses.
I'm ready for silence.
How many more Barneys, Minto?
How many more are there?
How many more?
They're all safe.
They all left.
They all went to Grandpa's place in another city.
The farm.
Grandpa's farm.
And they are really being fed well.
Always.
She blinded me with science.
Also, Dante, welcome to Bamboo Ship.
Thank you.
Yeah, they're being fed well.
They get a good helping of creamed corn every day.
That is fresh from the farm.
And then they also get goat milk.
Can you drink that?
Can you drink goat milk?
They went to the farm up north.
Yee-haw.
Can we meet them anytime soon?
They're really busy.
Really, really, really busy.
Let's go!
Rodrigo, thank you so much for the five gifted.
And Felix, welcome to Bamboo Ship.
Thank you.
Any remaining Barneys or stragglers who deserve what they get?
No!
I wouldn't recommend it.
What?
Drinking goat milk?
I don't drink regular milk really anymore at all.
I only drink oat milk.
So... I don't know how long today's stream will be.
I've heard conflicting information about how much of the game we have left.
Mito-chan.
What?
Oh!
Hi!
What do you like?
Taka Mito!
Yorima A-nata!
My favorite art... I saw one... Hold on.
Hold on.
Let me play one for you that I saw on TikTok yesterday.
Let me play it for you guys.
Hold on.
I saved it because I was laughing.
Wait, where is it?
Where did it go?
No!
Wait, did they delete it?
No way, I saw it literally yesterday.
Oh wait, I found it.
I think this is it.
Okay, it's trains.
Oh, and buses.
And then it shows for their favorite flavor.
It shows...
It shows for their favorite flavor.
It's like coal.
And for the bus, it's like...
It's like petroleum.
Yeah.
Coal and electricity.
Yeah, it's so good.
So I was laughing about that.
Good afternoon, Mintero.
Good afternoon!
Coal yorimo a-na-ta.
But um, yeah.
So, I don't know how long today will be.
I guess we'll...
Just play and find out.
Me and my best friend just took our relationship to the next level!
Oh, we bought a Lego set together.
What kind of Lego set?
Because that also really determines the friendship.
Or not...
The relationship, I'm sorry.
The relationship level.
You should later check out the prototype model for Gordon.
Also known as Lumberjack Gordon.
I will.
Barney's been to live up...
Live on that farm up north along with the goldfish from her childhood.
Yeah!
Yeah, I have betta fish.
Wake up, Miss Phantom.
Wake up and finish Half-Life.
I need to wake up.
It's such a...
It's such a sleepy day for me.
It's a sleepy day for me!
Star Wars Lego!
Okay, that's pretty serious.
That's really...
That's actually pretty serious.
Thank you for all your positive entertainment though.
You're welcome!
Was that good?
Goat cheese is a whole different game from cow.
I eat sometimes cheese.
EP Saturday is relatable.
I know!
Oh, and because I wasn't gonna initially stream today...
I guess I had it in my brain that I was like...
I don't know...
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna work on stuff today.
So I can...
But...
That's not the case.
Instead, we're playing Half-Life.
And that's okay.
We are here.
Forget about Freeman.
Right?
Yeah!
Forget about...
Forget about him!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
So...
Wait, hold on.
Let me see something real quick.
Uh...
Cutscene.
Not an actual...
Not an actual chapter.
So...
We can doubt it.
We got this.
Two of those chapters are really nothing.
Oh!
A couple of them are very short.
Alright!
I'm excited!
I can't wait to see the ending!
I wanna know what's going on with...
With...
The man!
The Hakai!
Oh...
G-Man!
I wanna see...
The man!
So let's get into it.
Oh, I still have my little snark in my hand.
I remember this part.
I got...
I could die here.
What is my...
Bullet situation?
Look at 13.
250.
121.
24 crossbows.
Uh...
Oh...
Oh, here's somebody.
Oh, here's somebody in there.
Um...
But I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna equip my revolver.
Equip...
Equip my revolver.
Reload my guns, maybe?
That's such a good idea.
Does this...
What is this usually at?
Okay, it's good.
This is...
Eight.
Yeah.
I guess that's one...
Oh, that one's at five.
Okay.
That one's always at one.
This is the energy beam.
Our little...
Or is this...
This is...
Not the snark.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna save just because I just reload.
So...
I'm safe.
I'm not safe.
Uh...
Let me out, please.
I'm not safe.
I was not safe.
Oh my goodness.
Is there a...
Is there a way I can crash jump?
No.
Okay.
Uh...
Understandable.
Oh my gosh.
Uh...
Okay.
I got it.
Oh, yeah.
Yes.
Not yes.
No, Marty!
I'm running!
You like!
Oh!
God.
I'm running!
Oh my god!
I don't think I should just be running.
Wait...
Um...
I think I'm in trouble.
Barney!
Barney, get to safety!
What are you doing?
We gotta... we gotta... we gotta get out of here!
Yeah, you should.
You should have a bad feeling.
Okay, I'm gonna use my crossbow and...
He's dead.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's a guy there, too.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay, I got his ass.
Ugh.
Okay.
Barney!
Oh...
We better be careful.
Yeah, we should.
Okay.
Let's see.
I'm scared.
I thought I saw something over there, but...
I guess it's a guy behind here?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, an ambush for real!
Ah!
Okay.
Hmm.
He knew!
How did he know?
My guy's so smart.
Maybe...
I'm trying to think of a different gun to use.
My target range time is gonna pay off today.
What just... what are you talking about?
Ugh.
Now you know when no one gets half the battle.
True?
Wait.
I think I got him.
Okay.
Oh, I only have four, though.
Okay, we're gonna have to be...
We're gonna have to be good.
Oops.
I'm warming up, you guys.
We're gonna get my hands on the guy who spawns
him.
Put C4 where they spawn!
That is so stinking smart.
Like, here?
Do you think Barney will get hit?
Oh.
Okay, Barney.
Just...
Oh, shoot.
I didn't think he would, like...
He would, like, toss it.
I didn't think it bounced.
I thought C4 was heavy.
Ah...
Rip Barney.
No!
He's blocked by...
Gosh.
No!
That's not what I meant to do.
Sorry, Barney.
Okay.
Um, hopefully...
We'll be fine.
I bet to press...
F7.
Ah!
C4!
Oh, my God.
Uh...
Critical.
It worked.
Don't even.
Don't even!
And Barney is...
Oh.
Another one?
It doesn't look right.
You're right, Barney.
This is so bad!
We're in a predicament, Barney!
I wonder if those boys could have made a bigger mess.
I wish I could...
Oh, gosh.
It doesn't help that there's two of them.
There's two of the big...
The Beemen!
Oh, gosh.
Take Barney with you.
That's for sure.
That will for sure kill him.
Lead him away.
Oh, you know what?
That's even better.
Okay, I'll cover you.
Come here, come here, come here.
Is this far away enough for you?
Yeah, I'll wait here.
This should be far away enough.
I'm trying to figure out what to do here.
What's the best course of action?
Maybe...
Maybe just grenade?
I only have four, though.
A fear for this thing.
Tripmine?
This is the tripmine, right?
Alright.
But doesn't...
Don't they have to be, like, close to this thing?
No?
I know, me too.
They have to touch the laser.
Okay, if I put it, like, here...
If we die, we die.
Okay.
I guess we'll just keep...
We'll just keep trying until we make it.
Maybe this...
This gun might be better, even.
Oh, I don't know.
Okay.
Put them everywhere where the dudes spawn.
Trial and error.
It's quiet?
It's not quiet.
It's not quiet at all.
Oh, my God!
Barney!
Barney, you did it!
He's a hero!
Oh, my God!
How did you do that?
You're amazing.
You stay here, Barney.
Oh, my gosh.
The goat.
The greatest of all time, actually!
Can I...
See, there's two ways we can go, it seems.
Okay, hold on, sorry.
Oh.
Dang it.
Okay, hold on.
Oh.
No, no, no, no.
I'm trying to figure out...
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, my God.
Okay, we're doing...
We're doing it!
I regret my retract...
Retract...
Earlier statement.
Straggler Barney for the win.
It's me, Gordon!
Wait, what is...
What's going on?
What is that?
Wait, what just happened?
What is this?
Oh, it's a snark!
Oh, my God, they're killing me!
They explode!
Dude!
Okay.
Redo.
They're like little fleas!
Oh, my God.
I got another one.
Good job, Barney!
He has aim of a God!
You should be playing this game, not me.
Those don't look like my snarks.
Mine are much cuter.
I think.
Okay.
So true.
Yeah.
Another one of these.
Okay.
Oh, what is that?
Oh, another thing.
Wait, I don't want to waste mine.
What if I do this?
Get me out of here!
Barney, save me!
Barney, I don't trust anybody but you!
Barney!
Barney, they're coming!
They're coming for me, Barney!
What was that?
He walked away.
He was like, this is your...
This is your...
Oh, wait.
I think they exploded.
Oh, they're exploding!
Stupids.
Apparently, Steve!
Thank you so much for the ticket to take you!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so we know...
The arrows are leading this way, but we know this room is kinda crazy.
So...
Get my crossbow out.
Reload it.
Okay.
Alright.
Got two of them?
Anybody else in here?
Got you!
I'm save scumming, saving after every hit.
And this will unleash the snarks?
That's what that does?
Yeah.
Barney!
That's a great question.
They'll explode.
This might not be the strat, but...
Might also be the strat.
Emotional support, Barney.
There's so much...
What is...
I don't...
Like...
So...
I'm assuming I have to...
Or maybe...
Do I have to kill these?
What is sniffing around in there?
You hear that?
Oops.
There we go.
We just ran away.
I don't have good enough aim to deal with these guys!
They'll...
If it works, it works!
They're like, what?
Is this a...
Oh, is this a...
No?
Oh, this...
Okay, hold on.
Before we...
Empty that though...
I do want to see what's on this side.
You know?
Oh my god!
Let's see...
What's the best gun for this guy?
Maybe...
Uh...
This.
Where are you?
I guess I could've blown him up with this, but...
Whatever.
I hear another one.
Oh!
Barney help!
The fleas!
Dang it, I was trying to get both of the nests at once.
But...
Clearly that doesn't happen.
Okay.
Okay, maybe...
Maybe like this.
I feel kinda silly running away each time, but...
Barney, are you okay?
They didn't explode on you?
Alright, we're fine.
I should like try and lead them over here and blow up the...
The C4 that I left.
Maybe if I like...
Run over here this way, I can blow them up.
And I'll...
Go heal up!
I have no health left!
Unless there's some up here.
Did I miss one in here?
I know I picked up something.
What is this?
Oh.
Uh...
What did I just do?
Oh my god, no!
Barney?
Is this thing gonna come out every time I go down now?
Wait, what's this do?
Maybe I should...
Maybe I should not...
Brist pull levers.
No way.
Barney!
Barney, I'm sorry.
I didn't know!
Load for Barney.
Wait, how far am I?
How...
I don't think I killed this guy.
Yeah.
Easy.
It's fine.
Everything's fine!
I only have four grenades.
Okay.
We won't do it again!
Don't worry!
I missed everything!
Barney!
I missed every shot!
There goes another Barney to the farm up north!
No!
Guys, I missed every single shot.
It was...
It was pathetic.
It was sad.
We all saw it.
Okay.
We don't need to...
We don't need to think about it any longer.
It was...
Oh wait.
I can redeem myself!
Here...
Uh, well...
I'm just gonna keep...
It's fine.
Okay.
I'm gonna redeem myself!
It was impressive, was it?
Watch out Barney!
Wait!
No!
I hit it!
I hit it though!
No, I didn't.
Maybe I did?
Hold on.
You can't shoot them.
Oh...
Yeah!
You need to use the trigger.
Well, shucks.
How do I get in there?
Through the door?
Oh!
This looks like an ambush.
It kind of was.
Can I take that?
Wait, let me have that.
Can I take it?
I must be full.
Full on snarks.
Dang.
Okay, but let's just remember this area, just in case.
Can I use snarks?
On the demons?
Like, on the monsters?
Does it work?
Look at this guy.
Wow.
That looks crazy.
I never noticed that he's got an arm coming out of his chest.
Yes!
You can use Q to hot-swap the last and current gun.
I don't do that, only because I think it'll mess me up.
No.
No!
So much for trying the snarks.
They're not loyal.
I can't tell which one this is.
What's making the noise?
Oh.
Fuck the doors!
Okay, never mind.
Oh, he's running around.
Did someone just teleport behind me?
Who teleports behind you?
Oh, that personnel, kid.
Snark him?
You saw what happened last time.
No?
Oh, hello?
Ouch.
I got him.
It's okay.
I think there's another one.
Oh, yeah.
Yep, yep, yep.
Yep.
Oh, my God!
Ouch!
Oh, the homing beats suck!
What if I...
Wait, how do you use this again?
Um...
You, like...
These ones home.
Come back.
Oh, look!
Oh, I think that worked!
Awesome.
I think that worked.
Yeah, baby.
What else is in here?
There's some crates.
Hopefully some health.
I don't want to quite go on that yet.
Uh...
Oh, my gosh.
Is that...
Yes.
Just a little bit of armor.
Just the tiniest bit.
Oh, yes!
Okay.
That scares me.
Oh.
Nothing.
Okay.
Wow, he's tough.
No.
Delta, thank you so much for the 5th sentence.
Thank you.
Holy cannoli.
Okay.
Alright.
Get my crossbow ready.
Oops.
More snarks.
There's something on top there, too.
Oh, there's stuff up there, too.
No, no, no.
Stop, stop, stop.
No.
Like, let me get off.
Get me off this ride!
Okay.
Oh, I missed.
Oh, wait.
I think I can just jump here.
Oh, no.
I don't think I can jump this high.
Okay, hold on.
Where do I go, though?
Oh, duh.
I know where we need to go.
Remember, we need the...
The...
Oh, I think I'm hearing electricity.
We gotta lower the water.
Oh, just kidding.
That doesn't lower the water.
We go in.
Okay, watch.
Don't die.
What was I saying?
Watch the ladder.
Do you see the laser?
Oh, my God.
No way.
I can't shoot through the...
Oh, yes, I can.
That guy was gonna jump and he was...
No, no.
They said forget about Freeman.
They don't care about me anymore.
Right?
I wanna get rid of this thing, though.
Um, okay, hold on.
I'm gonna throw...
I'm just gonna throw a grenade down.
Wait.
Will it work?
I wonder.
Time to see.
Will I die?
Oh, it's a turret laser.
Oh, no.
Thank you so much for the spooky doll.
Thank you.
Aw, man.
But we can get it first, maybe.
Can I...
Say if I, like...
Can I duck underneath it?
Okay.
I guess that worked.
I'm scared of the men more than the monsters.
Oh, my God!
I didn't want to use a crossbow on you, but...
Whatever.
BabyCore, thank you so much for the vibe.
Good to thank you!
I don't see any men.
Come on.
Come on, guys.
Team...
Teamwork!
Let's work to...
Forget about Gordon!
Forget about Freeman!
Right?
That's what they all say!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, oh.
Hold on.
Uh...
What if I just...
Leave me alone!
Wait, was that another one?
No...
Shot?
Is that...
Is that one in the water?
Just a touch overkill?
Maybe, but...
Oh, it was the bits?
That were still flying around?
Little bits...
Flying around.
Okay.
I'll have my...
Revolver open instead.
Oh, wait.
I have full water.
Uh...
Full water?
I'm sorry.
Full health!
Sorry.
Just looking at the water.
Wait, didn't I just kill that guy?
So...
I should be able to jump on top?
Like...
The sound's...
Electrified.
Full of water, baby!
I'm full of water.
I actually am.
You're scared of me!
Oh, there's a head grab.
Uh...
Ah!
Okay.
I'm just gonna save.
Maybe it's just a radio.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
A rope?
Help!
Oh my god, not you again.
Oh my god!
I don't know how I didn't get hurt at all from that, but...
Wait, I can't...
Oh, I can only shoot with this in the water, right?
He came straight at me!
Where could he be?
You think he's still right there?
C4 him.
Pistol too.
Ah...
But pistol probably would take a lot of hits, huh?
Fish grenade.
I don't have so many, uh...
Oh my god, he is right there.
Oh my god.
I can't see!
Ow!
When did I switch to that?
Oops.
Okay.
We're fine.
Oh my god, he's stronger than I thought!
Okay.
I thought he would take like two hits.
He's tanky.
I can't...
I know the water is so opaque.
Oh my god, wait.
I can't see where he walked!
Okay, fine.
We'll...
We'll grenade him.
Think I got him?
Not even close.
What do you mean not even close?
Think he's still underneath me?
You can crouch by where you saved to see it.
Oh, true!
Oh!
There he is!
Aw, man!
Well done.
Okay, let's try it.
Can I shoot him through here?
Instead?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh!
Oh.
That was ineffective.
Hornet gun can get him?
True!
I love the hornet gun.
Reload, reload, reload!
Run!
Where are they?
Oh.
They can't go inside.
Okay.
Good to know.
Not the bees.
Do you think they're homing in on him though?
Hmm.
That's what I want...
Oh!
Wait!
Oh, no.
Oh, God!
Oh, no!
Wait!
What was that sound then?
Oh, my God!
Is that it?
I don't trust it.
Okay, okay.
Checking.
Oh, my God!
Oh!
That sounded...
That sounded promising!
Oh, my God!
Seriously!
He's the biggest fish ever!
Do you think that was it?
Okay, it didn't hit.
So, maybe.
No, I think I just saw him swim.
Oh, I forgot there's a man around.
It's too mis...
Is he eating the bees?
I don't...
Just fighting raw dog.
With my...
Oh, my gosh, bow!
I mean, my...
Crowbar!
Alright, let's try.
Save first.
Yeah, we have nothing to lose.
Two hits!
After all of that!
Two stinking hits!
What is that?
It looks like a bomb, no?
Two stinking hits!
The bee gun actually did work, though.
Yeah, he was already low because of the bee gun.
So, cool.
Um...
Now we don't have to worry about...
Stupid.
Oh, there's another gun.
There's another turret.
Right there.
Um...
Hmm...
I feel like I could get it through the bars, but...
I would have to be...
Exact.
Like that.
Okay.
We got six shots left!
No!
My revolver!
That was some fancy shooting.
Thanks!
Alright, let's just go, I suppose.
Hope there's no other big guy around.
Wait, what the heck is this?
Oh, I go through the hole.
Uh...
How do I get through this one?
Same way, crouch?
Oh, god.
Oh...
We made it somehow.
Let's go.
Damn it.
Uh...
Hold on.
Did mine get him?
Might have?
Oh, no!
Nope!
Okay, we got him.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh, please.
Please.
I can't...
I can't jump.
I don't know how.
Okay.
I know that I took out the thing, but I just don't trust it, you know?
I'm scared.
Oh.
Nice!
That scares me.
Why did they give us two med packs?
I'm scared.
Okay.
Save.
A lot of rocket launchers.
Yeah, it's like they're telling me something or...
Something.
No reason.
What if I bee him?
Go, my bees!
Bees!
This is actually helping the environment.
We're repopulating the bee's population.
Hello?
Oh shit.
Oh my god, they're all throwing.
Wait, is that a tank?
Oh, no!
It's a tank!
Uh...
Where's mine?
Hmm...
Uh, wait.
It's the red laser that follows, right?
Or...
Oh my goodness.
Stop!
Is this doing anything?
Oh, it did!
It totally did!
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
Uh...
No!
I'm gonna die!
Oh gosh!
Oh my god, that was so close.
Oh, he's dead.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Five HP!
That's not great.
That's not good.
Black Mesa Central Complex.
Oh my god!
That's evil!
That's so evil!
I don't even know.
I'm gonna manually save this one.
I don't know if I should keep the save for this.
So bad.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay.
The HEV suit has no confidence in you.
I have no confidence in me.
Why are we going down?
Where are we going, Gordon Freeman?
Grab the rockets.
Oh yeah, you're so right, actually.
Thank you.
That's a good idea.
Yeah, grab those extra rockets.
Oh gosh.
Don't die.
Okay.
We're fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, since I used all of them.
On the tank.
Good thinking.
Thanks, guys.
Is this the Lambda Complex?
It says not that.
Sorry.
Oh, I think it was this one.
Save it.
Okay.
We're going down, down.
Ooh.
I'm ready.
Oh.
My Geiger counter is going crazy.
Okay.
Maybe there wasn't anybody over there.
What's the emergency sound for?
Barney?
Oh, no.
Oh, Barney.
Barney!
He's the juice!
Wait, there's...
There's some armor over there.
He loves Mountain Dew, that guy.
He drank too much of the juice.
You think I can get it?
Ouch.
Maybe it wasn't worth it.
Hahaha.
I hear a critter.
Ouch.
I'm sneaking?
Woof!
That was close.
All clear, sure.
All clear.
Sure.
Exactly.
All clear.
Do I need to destroy this one, too?
Alright.
Stealth archery.
Yeah!
Okay.
We're doing so much better than before.
Hahaha.
I wish I could get some more...
Some more bow and arrows, but...
It is what it is.
I hear something.
Hahaha.
This is an oblivion stream now.
Who do you think is gonna win?
Uh-oh.
I hear bees.
Wait.
This is...
This is pretty intense music.
Uh-oh.
Sounds like someone's coming up.
Oh, he's down there eating them.
You see it?
They're eating him!
And then they're gonna eat me!
Snark time?
Oh my gosh.
That's a great idea.
Oh my god!
What are they doing?
They didn't do anything.
Oh my god.
Did they notice me?
Uh-uh.
Actually, since it's a crossbow, the ammo is called bolts.
Oh.
Um, actually...
They're Um, no.
Yeah.
I...
Oh, oh, oh!
He was never... He was never there!
I think we have to use the can or the tank to open that up.
No, that's what it seems like, at least.
He was never there!
My snarks suck!
They're stupid!
It's not the best situation.
But I will still save.
They're cute?
I guess that's true.
Ooh!
Ooh, isn't there...
Okay, they're still giving me rocket ammo.
Oh, golly.
Colby, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
I'm guessing I just... I'm gonna get this ready.
I don't know why.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
I'm so stupid.
Uh, I'm gonna reload.
Hold on.
There's a tank?
Can I use it?
How do I use it, though?
Like...
Oh!
Okay.
No!
Don't kill me!
I think you can use the cannon, too.
If I did this.
I'm gonna try one more time.
Does it have, like, a cooldown on it?
Yes.
Yes, it do.
Oh, my God.
Oh, and...
Oh, God.
It's...
It's not good.
Guys!
We messed up!
Oh, my God.
I messed up.
I messed up bad.
I messed up good.
I messed up.
I messed up!
The tank is not good.
The tank!
No.
Okay, I think that was the last guy.
Dang.
Guys!
That was a lesson for us all, huh?
It was a good lesson.
Shoot.
What do I want to use?
His bees against him.
Wait, what if I... Oh, no.
Ouch!
Bees on bees!
Bees on bees on bees!
Bees!
Actually, I don't know... He's gotta be still there.
That's him, right?
What if we...
Instead...
Oh, this is my last one.
Never mind.
Bees on bees.
Is he still there?
Actually, I can't tell.
If I die...
If I die, I die!
Oh, my God.
How did I...
How did I avoid that?
I really didn't.
What the hell is that?
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Wait, now they have turrets?
I don't think I'm gonna live this.
Oh, my God.
Alien turret.
Wait, did that kill it?
Did that destroy it?
The alien turret?
Oh, it did!
It did!
I'm so dead.
I'm so dead!
I'm bee!
Let's see.
How do I want to do this?
Oh.
I forgot that was my last one.
He didn't see me.
I wish I could throw c4.
Can I?
I killed his bees.
Go, snark gull!
Will he actually work for me this time?
That guy's just running!
That guy's not...
I'm trying to figure out...
Oh, okay.
Okay, I'm gonna reload.
I'm going to switch to this bad boy.
I'm gonna try...
and handle him.
Okay.
That's one guy down.
All right, now I'm gonna try and rocket the other side.
Holy shoot!
Holy cow!
I got bees after me?
Oh!
Oh, he already shot.
We got it!
Yippee!
Yeah!
We got it, we got it.
Okay.
Nice!
I'm just gonna go back to this guy.
Ow!
Oh, I thought you were dead.
Am I shooting in between?
Hold on.
Was I even hitting you?
I don't think I was.
I don't think I was shooting him.
I think I was missing.
I think I was getting in between his legs.
Can I open that?
Okay.
We're in the lambda car!
Oh my gosh, you guys, we made it!
Took us a whole hour in that level, but we made it!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, we made it!
Any health?
Anything?
In here?
In the car?
Oh my god!
Oh, that shot's it.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Why is it so serious?
Here we go.
Can I get in?
What's the car for?
What's down here?
What's gonna be waiting for me?
Oh.
Just some...
Just some head crabs?
Oh.
That guy is...
I see more.
Oh my god.
I see that one up there.
Okay.
I see health over there.
Dog versus crab.
What's down here?
Can I go down here?
Anything?
Can I get squished?
Oh, is it...
If you accidentally fall?
What the hell?
Mother Trucker, where the heck did he...
Where did he come from?
Where the heck did that guy come from?
Oh my god.
That area is coming up.
You guys are scaring me.
What do you mean by that area?
What's gonna happen?
I'm scared.
Oh wait.
There's a ladder.
My bad.
Oh my god.
Where?
I was trying to heal myself.
Where did he come from?
Okay.
I guess it's fine.
We've been in worse situations, huh?
Maybe?
Yeah?
Oh.
Wait, what about...
What's this area down here though?
Does this go to anything or no?
Who did this to you?
But is this the area you guys are talking about?
This looks like a boss fight.
Oh.
What was that?
Oh no.
It's these guys again.
Oh it's the...
These snipers again.
Oh my god.
Come back.
I'm too slow.
I got him last time.
I don't hear anybody.
I thought they said forget about me.
Why are you guys so obsessed, huh?
Oh, I'm...
Oh my god.
I just noticed my bullets.
Holy hell.
Okay.
No ammo.
I might have to redo this one, but I guess we'll see how it goes.
I'm just gonna like blow up some of these.
Maybe I'll get a lady.
In order to beat the puzzle, the game, you must solve this Sudoku puzzle.
Nooo.
Evil.
I thought I heard somebody.
Oh my god.
Got him.
I'm scared.
I feel like I should save.
Thank you so much for the bird.
Thank you.
That was a pretty good shot though, isn't it?
If I do say so myself.
Felix, thank you so much for the pink.
Hold on.
Kind of left a lot of people behind.
And they're not exactly going to ignore their last...
Last orders.
I guess that's fair.
Take up.
Thank you so much for the gifted.
I guess thank you so much for the gifted.
I thought I heard somebody.
Reload please.
Reload.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I think I'm too low.
Got him.
Okay.
What about anybody in here?
This looks like a trap.
Like if I destroy it, somebody's going to be behind here.
Okay, okay.
This is good.
This is, this is better.
This is better.
I heard all their feet.
I heard them.
It's kind of ASMR.
I kind of like it.
How many are there?
I want to destroy this, but...
Okay, what?
It's Q, right?
Okay.
Sorry.
I'm scared.
Oop.
She's styling on me.
Oh gosh, she snipes so fast.
That's gotta be everybody.
No?
Probably not.
I say that.
Why did I say that?
Can I go down?
Oh my god.
I wanted...
I was hoping that there would be a hole so I could get to the house.
What was that light there?
Oh.
Oh, I think it's just a reflection.
Kept you waiting, huh?
Thank you, Venom.
I hear no more...
I hear no pitter-patter.
This looks like an elevator.
There is a way to the health.
Yeah, there's gotta be.
Is it this one?
Surely they won't ambush me while I'm doing this.
Nice.
I'm also almost out of crossbows.
This really sucks.
This is really bad.
I will save though.
I did it without deaths?
Was that it?
Did we do...
Was that all of them?
All the girlies?
I guess so.
Otherwise, they'd be coming up on me, huh?
Let's go.
Good job getting through that part.
Oh, that was it.
Okay, let's go.
Just in case there's any head crabs.
Why are there so many things to blow up?
Head crab?
Where?
Oh gosh.
Oh, I'm surrounded.
I don't like it.
Ah, I don't like it!
Save.
I already did, right?
I'll save again, just in case.
Oh my god.
Okay, we got that guy.
Jump scare!
Bee jump scare!
And there was another guy.
I don't want to use my...
Maybe bees.
Bee versus bee!
Oh my gosh.
Maybe not bee versus bee.
This gun is better.
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch!
Oh my god.
Another guy!
Where are they coming from?
These guys are so stinking annoying.
Wait, you can...
Oh, this you can charge?
I think so, but...
I mean, we only have 11 left, so...
Oh, thank goodness.
I'm running out of ammo and everything.
This is so bad.
Oh yeah, the thank you for the reminder on the right click for the shotgun.
Thank you.
I'm gonna save.
Yeah, thank you for the reminder on that.
More ammo next room?
Oh, really?
Okay.
I'm trusting.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, Doctor!
I almost...
I almost blew your head off just then!
Holy cow!
I apologize, Mr. Freeman.
But I couldn't risk opening that door until I was sure you had scoured the area.
This is the last entrance to the Lambda Complex.
Every other has been sealed off to contain the invasion.
When we realized that you might actually make it here, we drew straws to see who should stay behind to let you through.
Obviously, I drew the short one.
Aww.
My colleagues are waiting at the tip of the Lambda Reactor.
Waiting for you, I mean.
For me?
The reactor is shut down right now, but you could activate it on your way up.
You'll have to flood the core anyway to get into the teleportation labs.
You're not authorized to know about those.
Oh.
But I can see you already know a great deal more than any one man is supposed to.
Uh, clearly.
Well, actually, I know everything and nothing, I think.
I fear...
I know everything and nothing.
I like this little table here for defense.
That's pretty cute.
Oh.
We got ammo, but what was that ammo for?
Not this.
What was it?
It was like spiky.
Oh, it was more...
More bolts.
Oh my gosh.
Thank goodness.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, you know what?
Screw it.
Whatever.
I'm gonna...
Sorry, guys.
I gotta go use the little ghosties room real quick.
I'm sorry.
But, um, you keep this guy company, okay?
You keep him company and...
Oh.
Uh.
Maybe he doesn't care for it.
You keep him company.
I'll be right back.
I'll be real quick.
Yay!
We're back.
We're back, baby.
Thank you for all that super chat.
Thank you guys.
What was that?
What did I just do?
Oh.
We're doing it now?
Okay.
Thank you, sir.
Don't die now.
Oh gosh.
They're giving me...
They're giving me armor and health.
Are we about to do a...
Are we about to do a bus?
Okairi tadaima.
Thank you.
Oh, do I have to take it?
What's over here?
Test firing chamber.
What was that?
Oh!
Are you in weapons research too?
Oh my gosh.
I built the gluon gun, but I just can't bring myself to use it on a living creature.
The gluon gun?
You don't look as if you have any trouble killing things.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh!
New gun?
Oh wait.
This thing also uses the same as...
The same as...
Oh wait.
Oh.
This is the gluon.
This is the same as that one.
Interesting.
Oh, what the hell?
Can I redo?
I have to hold it.
Oh.
I ended up getting hurt for nothing.
It's kind of lame.
Oh, but it uses...
I feel like I'm wasting a lot of it.
No?
I wish there was more ammo.
Mister, you got any more?
You got any more ammo?
It's the best weapon in the game.
Oh, hell yeah.
Yeah, I'm like a head crab.
I know.
Hold on.
I'm gonna reload.
And we're just gonna grab it again.
But I'm not even gonna do the test.
I'm just gonna grab it and go.
Thank you.
Were you in weapons research too?
But I just can't prove myself to use it on a living creature.
No, because if you have any trouble killing things.
Okay.
Thank you, sir.
Don't press those buttons.
Do not press those buttons.
Don't do it.
You hold down the right click, it makes an animation.
Like while it's firing or...
Here we go.
Oh no, just normally?
Oh, it's like...
Doing a little shaky.
Or no, I'm doing that.
I'm holding down right.
Nothing's happening.
Ssss.
Uh oh.
Oh.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I like how they say die.
All right.
Hold on.
I'm gonna equip not this.
We'll use it for...
We're special situations, right?
Oh my god.
Where the hell did you come from?
You asshole.
Oops, wrong gun.
Wrong gun.
Oops, oops.
Seriously?
This sounds so bad.
There sounds like something everywhere.
Okay, I'm gonna test it out on this guy.
I'm gonna test it out on this guy.
You missed the first shot.
I know.
He was like about here.
Wowie powie.
Holy cow.
He's going to obliterate me.
I'm gonna die.
Oh my god.
No, not like this.
Not like this.
That wasn't good.
That wasn't very...
That wasn't nice.
That wasn't very nice.
Thumbs away!
Can I get him from here?
Oh, oh my god.
No kidding.
What the bees?
Oh, I forgot.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no.
No, no.
Please.
Please let me out.
Actually, I lied.
I don't want to...
I don't want to leave.
Please.
Oh my god.
Locked yourself in a murder cage.
What is this hell?
This is where I can't...
Okay, yeah, yeah.
What's going on?
I guess we'll go maintenance station.
Box reactor access.
Okay.
Barney!
Oh my god.
What are you doing here?
Your luck has to change sooner or later.
Shenzel Air, thank you so much for the tag gift.
And thank you!
Oh yeah, you would think, right?
You...
You would think, right?
This is the evil room.
Maybe not.
Actually, I don't know.
I'm just gonna save.
Oh, scientist!
You'll need to activate both pumps and flood the reactor.
And then that access pipe down there will take you to the core.
Time is short.
Oh my gosh.
Let's go.
They know that this area is kind of torturous.
Okay, let's go.
Please move.
Alright!
Now we're talking.
Expansions in the future.
Maybe.
He's just talking to himself.
Alright.
I think if we...
If I use this... Okay.
I can finally afford a membership.
I've been watching since the olden days.
For the best we thought, also use a dork.
Thank you, Benny!
Thank you so much.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I'm stuck on something.
Oh, I got stuck on... Oh my god.
Let me help, let me help, let me help!
Okay.
Alright.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Please.
Hell room.
It really is a hell room.
I think... He was the... He was the big guy.
The super gun.
Maybe, yeah.
There's one more guy.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, the one guy noped out.
But I got him.
Oh, wait.
Where'd he go?
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, he... Wait.
Like, you guys saw him, right?
He, like, ran that way.
I don't die.
I didn't think I killed him.
Health back.
Oh, your sacrifice was not in vain.
Thank you, scientist.
I didn't see him die.
Yeah, me neither.
Oh, my serious.
Okay.
Well, we took care of that room.
We took care of that room.
And now I guess we go down...
Is that where he went?
What do you think?
Oh, my gosh.
Oh,
I think I missed!
Stop shooting me!
Where did that guy even come from?
I thought I took care of everything around here.
I hear more.
I guess you're... I guess they're never fully gone, huh?
This is really nice looking water.
Like, this looks like such a nice room, though.
Like a nice swimming pool.
I had a feel...
The hallway was way too long for that to not happen.
Screw it.
I don't want to deal with you.
Okay.
It's quiet.
It's not quiet.
You know what?
Screw it.
Okay, we got him.
Close quarters shotgun.
Isn't that how it's supposed to be?
So what's going to happen when I activate this?
Is it going to start flooding and I have to, like, run back?
Actually, I'm just going to reload and then...
No, we're not in the best position here, but...
Oh gosh, we got...
We were at a hundred ammo...
Or a hundred arm...
A hundred armor, a hundred health.
Oh my god.
No way.
I don't want to deal with you.
These guys are the worst.
And they...
They deal such a stupid amount of health, I fear.
No!
I shot him!
Just a little nibble of my head.
Oh, there's one down there.
Wait.
Nice.
Shoot-in'.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I see how it is.
Oh, there he is.
Perfect.
Mince playstyle appears to be conservative about ammo like most people are about health potions.
I mean...
They only give you a limited amount.
Wait, do I have to go down there?
Oh my god!
Excuse me.
Rude.
Wait, do I have to remember this?
Pump one, tank one, tank...
Do I have to remember this?
I see the lever.
Okay.
Pull the lever, crunk.
Please, go down the...
There we go.
Okay.
Did that do the thing?
Do I just go to the other side now?
Yes, you did it.
Oh.
Neato!
I think so.
Okay.
Cool.
Oh my gosh.
I'm shrimping playing this game.
Hold on.
I'm like a shrimp right now.
What if I go back to...
Oh wait, I think I used all the ammo, but...
Let me see if I go back here.
Hey Barney.
I think there was still some health left.
Not much, but...
Oh!
Look at that!
Hey Mr. Look, I did it!
Okay.
Shrimp phantom.
Beep, beep, beep.
I'm just a shrimp.
This is messed up.
This is actually messed up.
Ouch!
My HP!
I'm not even gonna save.
If we...
If I have to do it again, I will.
What does that mean?
Wait, what?
Okay.
Seems bad.
Yeah, seems pretty bad, huh?
I'm gonna switch to my crossbows.
Maybe this will be easier.
And I'm gonna switch to...
I don't...
I can't use this gun for very much longer, so...
Wait, I can use it ten more.
Oh, shoot.
And that's that!
Whoop!
Still got rockets, true!
Where'd he go?
Wait, where'd he go?
Oh my god, there's ropes!
He died?
I killed him?
There's health over there!
There's two packs of health!
That's huge.
Oh my gosh, that's huge!
I got him with the crossbows.
I'm just so good!
Any others?
I think I got him.
All right!
Onwards!
Onwards and upwards!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
That was...
RUDE!
Oop, there we go.
Let's reload.
My health!
What's going on in here?
Oh golly.
So much for the health packs.
Well, they helped enough.
I for sure helped.
Without them.
Would have been done-zo for sure.
Pump station.
I imagine it's going to be similar to the other room.
I'm just going to save, but like, new save.
I imagine it's similar to the other room where those guys are going to pop out of nowhere.
Like they're going to spawn.
But then we also have...
Why didn't I come this way first?
This one seems harder because we got the tongue men's too.
Wait.
Oh, I thought I saved.
Oh, I did save.
Wait.
Hold on.
You.
Where was he?
You guys see him?
Anywhere?
Where'd he come from?
Plenty of HP.
There he is.
Nice eyes.
I saw him.
Because I'm wearing glasses.
There's armor down there.
Thank you.
All right.
Pull the lever.
And we skedaddle.
Let's get out.
Oh, it's moving now.
Does that do anything?
Or...
No?
Maybe not?
Okay.
I'm like so weary of things spawning, you know?
Spawning behind me, I mean.
We're not doing so high!
I haven't played it a long time, but aren't small boxes with lightning on them breakable?
With lightning?
They are?
The ones with the lightning?
I thought only the wooden...
Like this?
Wait.
This looks like...
It looks like it means it'll explode.
I think this just explodes.
Oh, which I should have been shooting at it instead then, huh?
They...
Go...
Boom.
All right.
So now that I'm here...
And we did this...
Do I go in here?
Uh...
Scientist?
I pulled your levers.
Scientist can heal you.
Oh, that's all right.
You're right.
Hi, Barney.
Hey, Barney, Barney, boy.
Don't linger, Mr. Freeman.
You've turned on the pumps.
Now take the access pipe, flood the core, and get on up to the labs without delay.
Can I...
Can you heal me?
Allow me to treat that injury.
Oh, thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
Wow!
He gave us so much health!
Wait, you stay here.
Yeah, you stay here.
Dang!
That was huge!
I know.
Wait, so I have to take the...
Pipe?
Is that what he said?
To where?
What is he?
Down there?
Swim?
Oh, there's a ladder.
Oh, oh.
Oh, thank goodness.
I was about to be like, um...
Okay, here we go.
What do I hear?
Okay.
I'm not stalling.
So...
Do I...
Okay, I guess I just...
Open these up.
The lightning guy.
Okay.
All right.
And then we do this one.
Go, go, go, go!
Oh, that's not a guy.
Oh, I see.
I'm up there.
Can I get him from here?
I did...
Oh, no.
I...
I did, and I did.
I did.
I did that.
Is that the only guy?
Oh, gosh.
How do I know where they're going to...
What is that?
Okay.
Oh, my...
My health!
Oh, my gosh.
I'm dying.
Holy crap.
Uh-oh.
I didn't even notice.
My bad.
Oh, no.
That guy...
Oh, I did kill him still.
Okay.
All right.
Let's just not stick around to...
To admire.
Oh, shoot.
Ow!
Oh, I got hit.
Ouch!
Ow!
No, no.
Please!
Uh-oh.
I'm at one HP again.
Okay.
Yeah, don't hang around here.
I didn't notice that they were, like, going around in circles before.
Oh!
Right in front of the door!
Okay, okay.
Oh, my God.
Did I get hit?
I don't know, actually.
Oh, my God.
Please!
Watch your head, Gordon!
This one's fast.
Okay.
Come in!
Messed up.
Messed up!
Wait for it to come back around.
Oh, please, please, please.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Oh.
Is it...
It's...
It's also ran...
Oh, my God.
It's not random, but...
Oh, my gosh.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Oh, please!
Stop, stop, stop!
Stop, stop!
Holy cow!
I only got hit a little bit, actually.
So...
Could be worse.
Does it go through the door?
Oh!
Scared me!
Okay.
Never mind.
Surely nothing got past those lasers.
And could get to over here to the reactor core.
Surely!
Why'd they give me so much stuff?
Up we go.
I made it.
I made it!
More supply?
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
More supply.
Uh-oh.
More supply!
What's down here?
Okay.
All right.
27-year-old scientist with PhD saying things like hot dog, ouchy, ouch, nido, and dog dog.
Oh!
Barney!
Hey, Mr. Freeman.
Hi!
Hello!
Yeah!
You're doing well in here!
Hold on.
I want to see what's down here first.
Is it just in case you fall?
What's the point then?
What's the point?
Wait, can you make it to the other side?
He's seen some shit.
Clearly.
Wait, can I jump over it?
Push the crate?
No.
Tough with the pipe.
It must be...
I guess you can...
I guess it's a shortcut from the other side.
Yeah, I think it's a loop around.
Shut the door, Barney.
Oh my god.
This is why I told you to shut the door, buddy.
Yeah, he listened to what I said.
Oh gosh, they're just gonna be ambushing from now on too, huh?
Oh, I'm reloading.
Oh god.
That's not good.
I really just went up to his face and was like...
All my health.
Let's redo that.
Okay.
Let's just redo that part.
And I'm gonna do it with my Karasbo instead.
And then I think a second guy.
Good job, Barney.
Good job.
Okay.
And then there's still this guy here.
Oh my gosh.
Excuse me.
Well, um, I could have gone better, I suppose.
Nice shot, thank you.
Alright.
What is this?
Oh, it turns on the... Turns on the gas.
What the?
That was a G-Man, no?
Oh, can I get these guys from here?
I'm guessing this is a... I'm guessing this is a glass.
That was him.
Let's try it anyway.
Never mind, it's not gas.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Oh, no.
I just made that harder for myself, huh?
Wait.
Where did you come from?
Are they just respawning?
I hear another one.
Oh, man.
They are endless, I think.
Oh.
I don't know.
Can I get in here?
Doesn't seem to be the case.
Guess we gotta go around.
Which, uh, let's go back to this.
Hold on.
I'm gonna have my secondary gun.
As that.
Okay.
I don't know if it's good that I turn these on.
Can I get through now?
Oh, you can go through the yellow ball or the green ball.
I don't know, but it's good that I took these.
Or I turned these on.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait.
I think they're dying to it.
Because I definitely didn't get that gun.
Yeah, they died to the steam.
So it's good.
It's good.
Yeah, I cooked them.
It's so bad, I still can't differentiate the different sounds that the craters make.
I'm still so bad at it.
Reload?
Oh, thank you.
I want all that sweet, sweet health.
Well, I guess I don't need it right now.
Oh!
The yellow orb goes here.
Wait, the green orb goes there and the yellow orb goes there.
Oh!
Oh.
Am I okay?
Did I sustain the injuries?
Maybe not.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Holy cow!
I have sustained a lot of injuries from the fire!
Or from the steam!
Oh my god!
That's a lot of damage!
I don't know when I last saved.
Oh wait, I think I saved in there.
I think I saved right before this, so we'll just run out.
Okay.
As long as they don't respawn.
Steam, not even once.
Oh, this is, this is the bees guy, right?
Oh, look at this, unfortunately.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Stop shooting bees!
Oh my god.
Stupid homing bees.
Now he'll come back through and he'll die to the steam.
Get steamed!
Oh.
Uh.
Get s- Uh.
Steam?
Wait, did he?
I can't tell.
If he died on top of the other guy or not.
Is that a valve steam reference?
He made the dying sound?
Oh, you heard it?
Okay, I'm trusting you guys.
I'm trusting you guys.
I only have six bolts left.
It does look like two.
Okay, I think we're good.
Six shots.
Oh, never mind.
Okay,
so I have to teleport in when there's something underneath.
Or else I'll get squashed.
Probably.
What's down here, though?
I'm guessing if I just fall through.
Ah, okay, never mind.
I can walk through here.
Okay, good to know.
Have you played Portal, Minto?
I have.
I feel like Portal was definitely, like, one of my first, like, games that I played by my, like, that wasn't like a, like a visual novel or a, oh yeah.
Ready?
So, wait, how?
Oh, wait, that's right.
You have to go through the opposite one.
And, wham!
Okay, I'm on it now.
And then I have to go into here.
But you know what I mean.
Oh.
Oh, I made it.
I made it in here.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I did it.
Oh, this spooked me.
Let's go.
Okay.
We did it.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Cool.
And we have an extra health, just in case.
Anything goes awry.
What about up there?
Do I not need to get up there or anything?
Pretty good shape, too.
Oh, not bad.
Hmm.
Well, there is a downstairs, so...
Oh.
Doctor.
Wait, could I have gone back and do that?
Could I go back and do that puzzle?
Or is it...
Is that where I am right now?
You are here.
Level C.
C for creepy.
The most confusing part of the game?
Oh, no.
Is it because we have to...
Zap ourselves back and forth between places?
Oh, golly.
Look at the code.
Wait.
Oh!
247.
I didn't even see it.
It's dying.
Oh my god.
I didn't even see it.
Oh.
247.
My gun is, like, perfectly in the way.
For me to not see it.
247.
Wow.
Oh, wow.
Oh my gosh.
What is going on in there?
Wait.
Can I...
Oh, I can get up here, I think.
Oh, we can get above.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
Don't fall in.
Gordon, try it myself.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh.
Is there anything else we need in here?
It's just a little secret?
It's just a little extra area?
Okay.
I'll take it.
Free supplies?
Sounds good to me.
Okay.
Alright.
Very nice.
Okay, so let's go back to up here.
Obviously.
It's the only thing we can do, I think.
I'm confused.
Where are we?
Um.
I think you're asking the wrong ghost.
Oh, so I went into port...
What?
No.
Because I went in through that...
Oh, wait.
Each side is port two.
I don't remember going in through the...
So...
Hold on.
I went in through port two?
Done.
I went into three.
Three.
Oh, okay, okay.
So two, and then four, and then seven.
Aha.
I naruho do.
Oh.
I didn't consider...
Um.
You know what?
Let's up.
I did not consider having to time the other parts.
That's so evil.
Wait, this is so evil.
But I don't even know which...
Uh.
So I guess that one?
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Ah.
We'll be safe scumming here a little bit.
Where does one go?
I'm curious.
Oh.
Let's see where one goes.
I didn't mean to use that on you.
Oh, it's this room!
With all the head crabs!
Oh!
Oh, do I have to go through here?
I really don't want to.
Uh, we can come...
I feel like we can come back here.
Yeah, where we saw Jimin.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, are you kidding me right now?
Oh,
you saw Jimin?
BTS Jimin?
Ugh.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm full on grenades!
Never mind.
That one is so fast.
Oh, this is one.
Oh, I almost went.
Nice.
Okay, four.
Oh, no!
Holy...
Holy cow.
Wait, don't go through that.
Seven.
Holy cow.
No!
Oh!
Strongest toes.
I can even imagine him, like, literally, like, gripping it.
Like, so...
Like, his toes are like...
He's just like...
Oh, my goodness.
Gracious.
Okay, this part's gonna be a little tricky now, huh?
Okay.
Oop!
Ah!
Where's the entrance?
There?
Oh.
Oh my toes are doing the work again.
I came from... Okay, that's where the code was.
I came from... There?
Do I just go to... Or do I crouch and jump in here?
I'm gonna die.
Okay.
Oh gosh, I just noticed there's this thing too that comes down.
Oh my gosh, please.
Please.
So I have to get to like two or... There's a button on one of the rings?
Is there?
Hold on.
I'm trying to see if there's anything.
We're on the worst carousel ever.
Check the door number.
This is what I'm... Like, do I jump over to the... Oh, they do have buttons on them.
They do have buttons on them.
Okay, okay, okay.
We'll go to... We'll try to... Oh, why did I do that?
Okay, just kidding.
Just kidding.
Alrighty.
Just a joke.
A silly joke!
Okay.
And then that probably... And then two will lower it.
And then we... Okay.
Alright.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Alright.
Save that.
We... Press the button.
Now we go back... In.
And we go to two.
And then we go...
Ooh.
Whoop!
Oh my God.
Please.
Yes!
Alright!
Who designed this?
That's a great question.
Who?
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oops.
Oh, I am jumping.
Guys.
Oh no.
My fingers hurt.
It's okay.
It probably saved when we came into this room.
No.
Wait.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
There's a four minute difference.
Right?
Okay.
Okay!
I can't believe my fingers hurt.
This is why you don't have...
This is why... We just have to press the buttons again.
But it could be worse.
Oop.
This is why you don't have the quick save and the...
And the quick load right next to each other, huh?
See?
Number one.
Easy.
Legit was sweating over here.
Oh, the time!
Why was it saying that?
Like...
I think...
Is that like...
I don't know.
I have no idea why there's such a...
A crazy amount of elapsed time between...
I don't know.
But, uh...
It is what it is.
It's okay.
It's time between saves.
Oh...
I see.
Alright, we're good.
Okay.
Now we just go to number two.
Easy peasy!
See?
Just like that, guys.
It's like nothing...
It's like...
It's like we didn't lose any time.
I'm too good.
First try for real, for real.
Alright.
And...
Jump.
And crouch.
Nevermind.
Okay.
And...
Jump.
Oh.
I'm just not even gonna quick load myself.
I'm just gonna let the game do it for me.
Hey!
We made it!
Okay.
Ikimasu.
Oh!
Now I'm on the other side!
Okay.
What does...
Don't enter this one?
Where does this one take me?
Gordon Freeman more like Gordon Feetman.
Yeah!
Try it.
This one?
Save then enter?
Okay.
Understandable.
There's big badness going on in here too!
Big badness everywhere.
Oh!
Hello!
Uh...
Collateral damage!
Anymore?
I like how politely they've just come crawling out.
You know?
Can't tell...
If I killed something or...
Those are the bees.
Are we going in the hole?
Far in the hole!
Ooh!
What if I do this?
Oh.
Dang it.
Okay.
Oh.
I guess we're going in the hole.
Oh!
Uh...
I didn't do that.
That was definitely them.
Wait.
There's a ladder here.
Oh gosh.
It's so spooky.
45% Thank you.
I didn't kill him.
It totally wasn't me.
That would be crazy.
Right.
What a thrill.
That don't sound good.
Doctor!
Hold on.
Before I go in there.
Is there anything in here?
No?
Okay.
And Barney!
Let me in!
Let me in, mister.
You finally found us.
So this is the guy.
We thought you'd never make it.
This is the supply depot for our first survey team.
Quite a few handsome specimens were collected from the border world.
And brought back this way.
Before the survey members started being collected themselves, that is.
We suspect there is an immense portal over there.
Created by the intense concentration of a single powerful demon.
This guy is freaking out.
You will know it when you see it.
It's okay.
Calm down.
You don't have to keep...
He's twitching.
You better kill it.
What am I killing?
You owe us nothing, Mr. Freeman.
But you've come this far.
You know as much about these creatures as anyone.
Enough to know that if you don't wipe it out, there won't be much for you to come home to.
True.
So...
If you're willing, my colleague is waiting for you at the main portal controls.
He will open the gates for you, Mr. Freeman.
Do hurry.
Okay.
Don't forget to gear up.
And I'll cover you while you're waiting for that portal to warm up.
He'll cover me, Barney!
Sweet man.
Sweet barn.
Sweet barnster.
Oh my gosh.
Uh oh.
Is this...
Guys, is this like the final battle?
Is this like...
What is this?
There's everything in the world here.
Is this the final battle?
No!
Aw man.
Oh my god.
What is this?
What is all of this?
Oh my god.
They were like, by the way, if you didn't get any of these guns, here you go.
If you forgot to get them.
What was that?
What are you doing?
I will understand soon.
Almost done with the intro.
That soon the game will begin.
Reload your guns.
Okay.
This Mr. Freeman is a long jump module created expected for navigation in the world beyond.
I certainly hope you received long jump training.
Because once you're in Zen, you will need it.
I would advise you to practice before crossing over.
I...
Just now...
Just now I'm getting the...
The...
No kidding.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm not ready.
Don't open the door.
Hope you remember.
Wow.
They give you even more...
They give you even more health.
They give you health packs.
So many health packs.
And then...
Even more health.
That's insane.
I don't remember how to use it.
Uh...
Okay.
I'm gonna reload everything.
I'm gonna reload every...
Oh, okay.
It's reloaded.
Just kidding.
Reload.
Nice.
That's good.
That's...
This is all good.
Okay.
This is...
I still only have 11, but...
I'm gonna save...
And then I'm gonna...
It's not...
It's not doing anything.
Wait.
Why isn't it...
Just run and crouch jump.
Yeah, that's what I'm doing.
Come on.
It's my birthday!
What's up?
Wasabi-san!
Happy birthday!
Jump while crouched.
I was trying before, though.
Like that?
Okay.
For some reason, it doesn't feel like it does much of a difference.
You guys are bad teachers.
He's like, crouch!
And jump!
I'll notice a difference in Zen.
Alright, well...
I guess this is it.
Am I in Zen?
Do you feel...
Feel Zen?
Not really.
There's a scientist up there.
Is...
Am I in Zen?
Yeah!
Okay!
Wait.
I'll practice it up here.
Might be better, huh?
From like...
Oh my gosh!
I'm kind of trying it...
Okay.
I messed up?
Hold on.
I'm gonna save when I'm up there.
It's dead.
Okay!
I thought I was gonna be in like...
Zero gravity mode.
I don't know why.
I'm not playing though.
I was lucky enough to get a membership.
Ooh!
Thank you!
Thank you, Chris!
Yes!
Heh heh.
I'm back...
Um...
Is there another place...
I can practice?
Let's see...
Maybe...
Okay!
Oh!
Understood!
I have a friend who is so dense about this game that he made all the gang hate this game without knowing a thing about it.
What?
I'm assuming that...
What the hell is that?
Oh my god.
What are those?
What are you?
Alien babies!
Oh my god.
I'm really bad at shooting at these guys.
Holy cow!
Hello?
Oh my god.
I'm not good at shooting at you at all.
Kill the babies!
Oh no!
Mister, I'm not good at this!
I need...
Barney!
Barney said he was gonna help me!
Oh my god.
Barney said he would help me!
You're almost there, Freeman.
Put yourself in position.
Barney said he would help!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Woo!
I missed!
She shoots!
That's okay.
I kind of want to redo that part anyway.
Cause the babies...
I want to practice with them.
Maybe...
Cross...
How...
What would be good for these guys?
Maybe the bees?
Cause they can home in on them.
Maybe the bees.
I thought I saved also at the top of that.
But clearly I didn't.
Revolver?
Oh, Revolver would be good.
Practice your long jump if you must, but hurry up!
Tanya, thank you so much for the vibe!
Thank you!
Okay.
Now I'm gonna save.
Okay, here we go.
Ha ha ha ha!
Revolver would be good?
Alright, I'll try it.
Here, I'll even have...
I'll have this to switch between.
I was so close!
I went...
Too far to the left.
Ha ha ha ha!
I don't have to jump from here?
Oh, I guess I could jump down there too, no?
Alright, I can open the portal now.
The process is complicated.
And once it's begun, I must not be interrupted.
Or I will have to start all over again.
Don't enter the beam until I give the okay.
Understood?
I will begin.
Yes, teacher!
Close doesn't count.
I know.
Ha ha ha ha!
You're right.
What does right click do?
Nothing.
Okay.
I couldn't remember if I did anything.
Oh!
The first guy!
Oh, I shot him down!
Click out!
I actually got him!
Oh my god!
I got him!
And they still spawn.
Oh!
They keep spawning.
Oh shoot!
They don't stop spawning and they don't stop spawning and they don't stop spawning.
Oh!
Whoa!
No!
Oh!
Get yourself in position.
I got him?
Oh my gosh, they just keep coming.
Here I go!
Oh, not yet.
Almost!
Here I go.
Here I am about to go.
Oh my god.
Can I go?
It's ready!
You must go!
Now!
Alright, I can open the portal now.
The process is complicated.
Once it's begun, I must not be interrupted or I will have to start all over again.
Don't enter the beam until I give the okay.
Understood?
Yes, sir.
I think I need to practice my job.
Oh yeah.
Oh my goodness.
There's a platform?
Oh my gosh, you're right!
There is!
Oh, oops.
Leave him alone!
He's just an old man!
Oh, I'm not doing so hot this time.
Leave him alone!
That guy died in mid-air.
That's my grandpa!
No!
Leave him alone!
That's my grandpa!
There.
Okay, cool.
Uh oh.
Oh, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Platform.
Oh, that's it.
There we go.
Yeah!
Hey, you must go!
Whoa!
Um...
I'm in Zen.
This is what they meant.
Oh!
I thought I overestimated it.
Oh.
Oops.
Oh, sorry.
I can't wait.
That's part of the game, Zen-haters aren't welcome here.
Oh?
Oh, yeah!
What the hell?
Why is it, like, shaking?
It feels like it's gonna fall.
It's scary.
Okay, let's go!
Hope you like platforming.
This is...
This might take a bit of a...
You know...
Oh my gosh, I barely made that.
Holy...
No siree!
Not on my watch.
Uh uh.
No ma'am.
Um...
What do I platform to?
What the heck do I...
That over there?
Oh my goodness.
What do I...
Oh, this one right there.
I missed.
The s...
The very slow-moving platform.
Major fracture detected.
Okay.
I got it.
I darn done it.
Okay.
Can I just jump to this?
Oops.
No!
Okay.
Maybe...
What is happening right now?
I don't...
I have...
Your...
Your guess is as good as mine.
Hup!
Oh!
Save's coming.
That's okay.
Um...
What's the next platform?
Is it that?
But I'm always just chasing it.
Uh...
I'm not quite sure.
Maybe it is.
Maybe I do have to jump over to there.
Just a little bit.
But...
That's okay.
Oh!
We'll take it, we'll take it.
We take these.
We take these!
Um...
Wow.
It's so pretty here.
Okay.
I'm mostly saving because...
They...
We have to like, kind of wait, you know?
So I don't want to have to always be waiting.
Oh.
One damage.
Tipsy!
One single damage.
Let's see.
I didn't even take damage this time.
I didn't even...
Where's the...
Where's the platform?
There it is.
Okay.
You?
Where?
Oh.
It's filled with dogs.
And beams.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Uh...
I'm gonna switch back to my revolver.
Where are we going?
Oh.
Limbo!
How can you go?
Alright.
What else is there?
Come here, dog.
Oh my gosh.
I'm...
Oh.
Ah!
Okay.
I don't think that...
What about these?
Did I save when I got down here?
You know what?
It's fine.
Um...
We're limboing again.
Oh.
I should crouch.
Okay.
I'm good.
I don't think I got that dog.
Oh, but I didn't get zapped this time.
Can I actually destroy this?
Let me try...
This instead.
Hmm.
Can we shoot that dog?
Bees gun?
You know what?
Honestly, that's probably the best idea.
Oop.
Hahaha.
Get them dogs.
Oh, they're fast though.
Hmm.
I wonder if they're too...
I wonder if they outrun the bees.
I'm just gonna go on.
I'm just gonna go up.
Um...
No.
Oh.
Boo!
Oh, the lights turn off when I walk past.
Look how cute!
Can't get me from behind here.
They're...
They're shy.
Just run.
That's what I'm about to do.
I'm gonna go into the magical puddle.
It's healing me!
What?
No kidding.
The puddle of healing.
I'll save here.
Ouch.
Hahaha.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Not...
Quite sure what to do here.
Is this like a little secret?
Crouch tunnels.
Yeah, yeah.
I noticed this one.
Secret tunnels.
Okay, let's go find them.
Let's go find the secret tunnels.
Whoa!
Ah!
I'm stuck!
Oh, there we go.
Don't need this though.
Okay.
Alright.
Uh...
Secret tunnel.
It has health in it.
But then what's the...
What's with the pool of healing?
Nothing.
Secret tunnel!
Whoa!
Oh, this is...
This is gross.
A weird place to put a health pack when you have healing water, right?
Unless you can like...
Hold heal...
Health packs.
Oh, we gotta let...
The butterflies free!
Oh!
The butterflies!
How do I get...
To the...
Over the...
Can I shoot this?
Maybe not.
The music is so pretty...
Ouch.
Okay, we're fine.
Oh!
I guess this isn't...
This isn't goop that will kill you?
Maybe?
It's not toxic.
Yeah, it doesn't seem to be.
What do you require?
Um...
What...
What do you require?
Oh!
Okay!
Oh, I got one?
Number two?
Oh, the butterfly!
Oh, come here.
Oh, so close.
Come, but...
Come, little butterfly.
Oh!
All right.
And...
Whoop!
Okay.
Little butterfly!
I get butterflies in my stomach every time I see mint.
Stop!
Sure it's not, Abby, yes?
Should I save, or...
Okay, I'm gonna save.
Okay, it looks like I go in that.
All right, here I go!
Oh!
Gonark Slayer?
The music's kinda funky.
Why does it feel like Doom?
Oh, did we just find Gonark?
Oh!
Oh, ouch!
Oh, okay.
See you.
Boss dive!
Holy cow!
Oh!
Oh, I can't hide in there.
Okay.
Just kidding.
Do I attack your sack, or...
Who was attack- Oh!
No way!
Does it make headcrabs?
Oh my god.
Miss.
Madam.
Mommy.
Oh!
Baby!
Oh, it's so cute!
It's not cute.
It's not cute at all.
It's actually...
It's killing me.
Oh, I can't go in here just yet.
Woo!
Mama!
Oh, what did I just grab?
Am I doing this right, guys?
Mama!
Oh!
Oh, shoot.
Yeah?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Don't attack me trees, please.
Woo!
Oh!
I just ran into her.
Oh my god.
The little baby headcrabs are still attacking after me.
They're so persistent.
Oh!
She just ran in there.
Nice, nice, nice.
Go after her.
I'm going, I'm going!
Are they still after me?
Maybe not.
Oh my gosh.
Why is this area so much smaller?
Oh my god.
I'm trapped.
Ow!
I'm trapped!
Oh gosh.
I just noticed the floor too.
Ooh!
Ah!
Oh my god.
I'm trapped.
Oh, I'm trapped.
Please.
Let me free.
Uh.
Okay, um.
Oh.
Okay, this is not so bad.
Oh, ouchy, ouch.
Yes it is.
Oh.
Where did I go?
Where am I?
Hello?
Ouch!
What if an udder had legs?
I see.
Ah!
Please!
Okay.
Thank you for the raid!
I'm...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
I'm in a boss fight right now.
So I'm a bit...
I'm a bit...
blessed.
Thank you for the raid!
Oh my...
Where did you come from?
I see there's more...
stuff in here.
There's a friend!
No!
Wait, what is the...
blue light?
Save?
Yeah, that's what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna save it.
Oh my gosh.
I just took health for that.
Hold on, let me...
let me just reload.
Reload.
Reload and reload.
Cause a guy's gonna come down here.
Maybe?
They live here!
What?
Oh!
Sorry.
Reload?
Reload.
Save.
Okay.
Jump.
What?
Can I not jump here?
Am I stupid?
Okay.
There we go.
Oh!
It's a healing pool!
Oh my god!
How did I find this little hole?
I don't know actually.
I don't know actually how I found this little hole.
She has so much.
Yeah, I just kinda fell into it.
She has so much HP.
Okay.
She's waiting for me.
Mommy dearest.
The hole found you.
Oh my god!
Oh shoot.
That's awkward.
No.
There we go.
Hey now game.
Hey now.
Suddenly it's like by the way.
You're gonna fall through every hole.
Careful not to save over this.
Yeah, I know.
I know.
A little guy comes down.
I'm waiting for him.
But...
Okay.
Can you shoot from under?
Oh!
There he is!
Can I shoot from under?
Oh!
I think it actually is doing damage.
Wait.
Wait, you...
No?
I'm the type of gamer who doesn't look down.
Through the gaps.
Like how big of a gap are we talking?
Like this gap?
The one I fell through?
I feel like I heard her making noise though, no?
Like she was upset.
Like that!
No?
Oh!
We lost her.
I feel like if I sit in there, the head crabs will keep coming down at me, you know?
Okay, hold on.
She leaves.
She moves!
She leaves!
We can get her from right here.
Oh!
There he goes.
Mommy, your babies are stupid!
I could use like a better gun for this.
Let's see.
Hold on.
Nice!
Chill out!
I don't know.
Maybe not this one.
Maybe a crossbow would be good.
And then...
Let's do a crossbow.
And then I'll have my...
My pistol on the ready for...
For these guys.
For you.
Okay.
Wait, did I hear one behind me?
I don't know, I can't though.
I think one's sneaking up.
No?
Am I wrong?
Maybe I'm wrong.
Okay, just kidding.
Alright!
SMG?
Oh, that might be good too.
Let's cheese her a little bit.
No, this is actually working pretty well.
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Shoot tanky.
Okay.
Come on.
Here we go.
And a one and a two.
But she's gonna run away into that hole, no?
That's where she's gonna go next.
When she's low enough.
No!
It does really just look like a big ol' teat.
It...
Oh, gosh.
I have one...
One more.
That's it.
Oh my...
Flashlight.
Um...
Oh my...
God!
Does she have iframes?
Because I feel like...
I would shoot her and...
It's getting redder?
Is it?
I don't know.
Are you sure?
Are you seeing what you wanna see?
Ah!
Try moving back up.
Okay.
She's waiting for me.
Alright.
I'll try going up.
Okay.
Before I do that...
I see that guy right there.
I see...
Oh my god!
Stop it!
Trying to get that guy right there.
And this guy right here.
I can't...
Okay.
I'm gonna save!
Save.
And...
Uh...
Jump.
And...
Heal.
I'm gonna heal and then we'll go up there.
Alright.
Get that guy!
Oh!
That's why I saved.
That's why...
I saved.
Baby!
Heee!
Oh!
Up!
Let me up please!
Please let me up!
Oh!
I need to stop falling through the hole.
I need to stop falling through the hole!
I really need to stop...
I need to stop...
Please!
Jump!
Okay.
Oh my gosh!
Jump!
Um...
What would be good?
Oh my god!
Uh...
Oh my
god!
Oh my god!
There's so many baby head crabs.
No!
Oh...
Okay...
Oop!
Maybe I should save here...
Instead of like...
You know...
Jump...
When I jump across...
Rockets...
I have five!
Let's try it!
Oop!
Taking a lot of damage!
Ahahaha!
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
I thought I was cheesing it!
Let's go back to this one maybe...
Oh gosh!
Please!
Don't kill me!
Little head crabs!
The babies are so annoying!
They're the worst part!
Oh!
Oh my god!
She's going!
She's leaving!
I almost had her!
Oh!
Did I die to a tree?
Okay...
Drop down the hole to heal in the water!
That's easier said than done, pal!
Buddy old friend of mine!
That's...
Much easier...
Said than done for me!
Okay...
Alright!
Ugh!
If you haven't seen how many times I've...
Okay, please!
Please!
Stop it!
Stop!
Okay...
Huah!
Save...
Okay...
Now...
Go ahead!
Jump back over!
I'm gonna heal!
Okay...
Alright...
Totally...
Yeah...
Totally intended...
Oh!
Oops...
My bad...
Flip!
This guy gets me every time...
Alright...
I have 10 left...
So I'm just gonna go back to the...
To the...
Huah!
Run back and forth!
Haha!
Oh my god...
Not the tree!
Thank you for the...
Thank you!
I'll...
Haha!
Should've written the balls!
Thank you!
Okay...
Uh...
Oh...
Oops...
Uh...
Go!
And...
Get in the...
There we go!
Please leave!
Oh, she's leaving!
Oh my god, finally!
Ouch!
Oh god...
That's not good!
Just kidding...
Ha ha ha ha...
Ah!
Wait...
One second please...
Leave me alone!
Okay...
Alright...
Now I have a second to think...
Okay...
Um...
Do I need the heal?
Because I'm at...
98...
Frick them kids!
Hahaha...
Probably...
Shouldn't have wasted...
Because I only have...
One...
I only have one left!
That's like my last strong weapon!
C4 will help?
Okay...
C4...
Yeah, yeah, yeah...
We do have C4 and grenades...
You're right, you're right...
You get more ammo later?
Oh, I do?
Okay, cool...
Um...
We'll reload on this...
Uh...
Reload...
That's good...
Okay...
I'll just hold on to this...
Alright...
Let's save...
And let's...
Let's go, baby!
Here, I'll save...
Actually, right here...
Okay...
How am I supposed to get down here...
Without, like...
Breaking my knees...
I guess like that...
Okay...
There we go...
Oop!
Oh!
This is not good...
That's not good at all...
That's not good...
That's...
Really not good...
Oh my god!
That's not good!
Ah!
Oh god!
Babies!
Babies everywhere!
I don't want...
Okay...
Um...
Oh my gosh!
Please!
Ah!
Crowbar!
I'm so true!
Stupid babies!
Damn!
They really don't stop coming...
Okay...
Alright...
Alright, mama...
Mama!
Ah!
Will this work?
Time to find out...
Uh...
How do I get back up?
Like...
Am I trapped down here forever?
Oh...
Nice...
Um...
Let's use our grenades...
You don't...
Other than reloading...
Gotta unload on her...
Okay...
Oh...
I don't think so...
We are getting her...
Cock the grenade...
Then throw...
I'm scared...
Here, I'm gonna save...
I'm not gonna quick save...
So it's like...
And...
Oh...
Where the hell?
Count to three...
One...
Two...
Three...
Oh no!
No, no, no, no!
Poor babies!
Come this way...
They're kinda cute...
Ooh...
Golly...
She still let him fly!
More!
Mommy!
Please!
Alright...
One...
Two...
They do do damage, you guys!
They are doing damage...
They do...
They do damage...
They're so stinkin' annoying...
Do do babies...
Please stop having babies!
Please!
I can't do this anymore!
Oh my god...
I do kinda wanna just unload on her...
Please!
Leave me alone!
I was hoping that she would...
Get into that...
How she was before...
But...
That doesn't seem to be...
The case...
Uh...
Oh...
I'm out of ammo!
No...
Stinkin' way...
Uh...
Oh my god!
Oh!
I'm stuck...
I'm stuck on the babies!
Oh...
Uh...
Did we...
Did we do it?
Stop!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna die because of the babies!
Babies!
Two!
Throw!
Oh!
That did actually hit her though!
Oh my god!
These stupid...
Stupid babies!
One...
Two...
Please!
Come here!
Come here stupid babies!
Stupid babies!
Babies hate!
One...
Two!
Nice!
One...
Two!
I...
I got something!
Babies!
Babies everywhere!
Oh my gosh!
More babies!
R slash no big...
No kids!
Get out of here babies!
I said they were cute and I...
I...
Don't mean it anymore!
Oh, that's right.
I was almost out of this one.
Oh my god!
As long as I start...
Kill them while I'm also attacking her.
I think it's...
Not so bad.
She just keeps non-stop having the kids!
Holy cow!
Shoot the sack!
I know this!
What do you think I'm trying to do?
Oh!
We got her!
Oh my god!
But there's so many freaking kids!
I keep getting stuck on the kids!
Yippee!
Woohoo!
Oh my god!
I'm going... I'm leaving!
Say yodoro!
Interloper...
Why is it shaking so much?
Oh!
Ouch!
Please!
Hold on!
I just made it here!
Please!
Ouch!
Oh my god!
There's guys everywhere!
Okay, this is not safe.
I need to...
Um...
I have one HP and a dream.
Probably gonna have to restart this.
Um...
Oh!
Well...
That's...
Oh!
Oh, oh, okay.
I was like, where am I?
Ah, please!
I'm stuck on the babies!
Okay.
Alright.
What is that sound?
It's gonna break anyway.
Oh, why am I going up the same way as before?
Okay.
Alright.
Maybe if I save here, it's okay.
Um...
Oh my god.
I don't...
Now what?
Yeah, now what?
That is a great question.
Um...
Things keep dropping from the sky.
And...
Uh...
Oh, there's a cave.
Maybe with health?
Oh, healing water!
Oh my god.
We got the...
We made it to the healing water!
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Worst enemy in the game incoming...
What is it?
The alien babies?
Because I hate those guys.
Alright.
We'll save in here.
100%.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This took me so long to figure out.
Let me try for a bit.
And then I'll...
Um...
See if I want any hints or anything.
Oh, uh...
Okay.
I'm in here.
Where am I?
This doesn't hurt.
I remember.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
No elk.
For now!
Okay.
Oh.
Stinking.
I never want to see another headcrap ever again in my afterlife after this game.
Which is funny because if I...
Oh.
Uh.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
That happened?
Wait.
Until Half-Life 2.
Oh, I know.
Why not?
Oh, I thought that was a headcrap.
That's funny.
Okay.
How do I have no more?
Oh my gosh.
That's crazy.
I wish I could hold on to more ammo.
I hear someone behind me, but I don't know where.
What the hell?
Oh.
It's this guy.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Uh.
B-b-b-bees.
Maybe is best.
Just wanna figure out where to go.
I'm going to save.
Maybe against my better judgment, but you know.
It's fine.
What is this?
Health pack!
Oh!
Okay.
Cool.
Thank you, alien planet.
How kind of you.
To kid or to me.
And my needs.
What's under here?
Nothing.
Okay.
I guess we go this way.
Rocket and health.
Cool.
I don't know why I thought that would work.
Med kits for guests.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh!
Um.
Uh.
Oops.
It's the longest pillar ever.
It's such a big burrito.
Oh my god.
Woo!
Uh.
Wait.
Oh my gosh, please.
Okay.
Aaaah.
Aaaaah.
God.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Combat platforming.
Oh.
Sorry.
I was blocking it.
Okay.
Zen is... yeah.
Kill them before going up.
I could just try.
Oh.
I somehow just did that.
Okay.
Don't hurt me, please.
He's like eating them up when I kill them.
Or... something.
Maybe not.
I thought he was.
Okay, never mind.
The devs apologize for Zen.
This is... this is pretty rough.
I'm not gonna lie.
Okay, we got one alien.
I wish I could go heal again.
In fact, we can.
Actually.
Oh my gosh.
All I have to do is go in here and we can heal.
And... oh my gosh, I missed the ammo.
Oh.
Uh, hello?
There we go.
Back to the Minto cave.
Oh.
We'll heal.
We'll take out.
Oh my gosh.
We're Nancy Drew in the onsen.
And at the Rio Con.
Zen has some nice onsen.
It's what I just said.
Exactly what I just said.
Alright.
I assume there's a guy in here.
Oh, he's right there.
Jerk.
This is my bath time.
Alright, so I...
I'm not gonna go back in there.
Where?
Did I get all the aliens?
Maybe I did, but I'm just not sure.
Do I...
When they beam, do I touch it?
I feel like I shouldn't, but...
I don't know anymore in this game.
Oh!
I don't know where that leads.
I don't know.
Um...
Oh!
I...
Stupid.
Think they keep...
No, I meant the...
I don't think the big aliens do, right?
The small ones...
Oh, shoot.
Forgot about that guy.
I don't see any...
Any alien babies.
Anymore, at least.
Oh...
I'm gonna die.
That was fun.
That was good.
That was harsh.
Okay.
Let me try again.
Oh, no.
Zap!
Beam me up!
Alien overlords, I welcome thee!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no.
Felix, thank you for the...
Ah!
Thank you for the pink.
Oh, my God.
I gamed.
I gamed!
I'm stuck.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know...
Elp time?
Yeah, I think so.
Maybe elp time.
Do I get up on the hydra's back?
Or...
Save?
Okay.
I saved.
Look to the left.
Is it that?
That's where I came from, though?
Go to the portal.
You need to enter that portal.
Oh, really?
Isn't that where I came from?
I don't know why I didn't think I'd get this far.
To the portal.
Do I have to ride on those guys' back?
Oh, he just died.
Catch a ride.
A little stingray.
This is like the worst one to be on.
I can't... Like,
I can't make it to... Ouch.
Okay.
Alright.
Unfortunately, I had to take damage for that.
Oh, gosh.
And sometimes, they dive.
Okay.
Good to know.
Sometimes, they just... They... Okay.
So, we need to go to the guys on the... Oh, my God.
Oh!
Hello.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Catch a ride.
Oh.
Huh?
Wrong way.
Let's figure it out.
We'll see.
I thought that's why... I thought I didn't come to... I didn't think about going to this portal, because I thought this is where I came from.
Woohoo!
Anything else to help me out around here?
Who is speaking?
My friend.
Oh, I think I keep missing.
Or, maybe not.
Maybe he got bored.
The bee gun.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, bee gun.
Oh, these are the tentacles!
Oh, it's this guy!
The one that doesn't like sound!
Oh, no.
I see.
What was that?
Okay, I'll be sneaking this whole area then.
What is that?
Oh, my gosh.
And the trees can get me.
This sucks.
Wait, is that the... is that bee man?
Uh-oh.
I think they know I'm here.
Shit.
Oh, my God.
That's definitely not the suit that's talking.
Something's talking.
Something's speaking.
Okay, so if I move, if I run, the tentacles come out it seems.
But I wanna jump some... I don't know.
I actually don't know.
Okay, let's see.
You don't hear anything?
It's like a very like...
Like that.
Oh!
Oh my god, I'm getting hit by the tree.
Sticking trees, man.
Okay.
There's a floating rock over here.
But if I... get this guy, then they know I'm here.
And then they're like, wee-woo, wee-woo!
So let's just try going in.
Who the heck is that guy over there?
He was throwing his hands around like he's yapping.
Oh, I think that's one of the zappy guys.
Yeah, that's one of the zappy guys.
Okay.
He's hard at work.
And he's being looked over.
I'm trying to figure out...
I have no idea.
I'm just gonna... I'm just gonna sneak in and see what happens.
Oh.
Run!
What the hell is this room?
Oh.
Wait, this sounds like... a healing room.
Please.
I hear water!
No way.
Oh, that's so rude.
That's so rude.
Don't even be like that.
New onsen.
Yeah, but now it's contaminated with...
with bits of monster.
Bit of alien.
Gross.
Maybe we can get some more stuff inside.
Go, go, go.
Okay.
Never mind.
Oh, this is where the nastiness was being pushed out.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's because I was walking.
Oh,
see, now they're alert.
The guards are alerted.
So, let's see.
I should have just taken them out anyway, then.
I should have just taken them out from behind when I had the chance.
Wait, but there is something over here, too.
He doesn't see me?
I'm too small.
I'm just an itty-bitty human!
Oh my god!
Holy cow!
I don't think the bees do anything against him.
I'm wondering if I should save or not, you know?
Only explosives or gluon works.
Oh, what?
Okay.
But what if we sneak past him?
Yeah, let's make a new save.
Instead of a quick save.
Okay.
I'm sneaking, I'm sneaking, I'm sneaking.
Cause I don't know if you guys remember, but I don't have like any ammo.
Oh, just kidding.
I have 65.
When did I get that?
I don't want to waste it all.
I see a hole.
Oh my god.
Cause there's no one in here, right?
Oh gosh.
I didn't see any other holes.
Safe.
Okay.
Oh my god, look at him.
He's kinda cool.
Oh, did he notice me?
Wait, he's also got an arm.
On his chest.
He's just a- Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Okay.
He's spawn camping.
Do I need to go up on- Is this an elevator?
Let me see.
Maybe not.
I don't- Is there- A way to even sneak past this guy.
He gets aggroed so easily.
Is it this right here that I go to?
I thought that's where I came from.
Oh- Or is this where I came from?
No, I came from over there.
Okay, so I go straight ahead.
Okay.
Oops.
Wait, why do I hear planes?
Yeah, I didn't know that was a pit.
Yeah, that's okay.
Shoot.
Okay.
We got this though.
We got this.
Why does it take so long to load?
Oh, that's- I was like, hello?
I didn't realize that it wasn't a loading screen.
I thought it was- It was my dead body lying there.
I thought it was a loading screen.
Okay.
We've got this!
He looks like a big...
Like a big roly-poly.
He's kind of cute.
The way he runs away is so funny.
Okay.
Oh, please.
Please.
Why can't I jump?
Why can't I move?
Okay.
Right there.
And there.
And...
Wait.
I don't know if this is...
Uh...
What...
Well, I guess it...
Could be worse.
Could be worse, huh?
Okay.
Let me actually try this.
And these guys.
Yeah.
And...
These guys.
But I'm full on health.
As long as I...
As long as I sneak, they will notice me.
Wait.
I might have used all my grenades on the...
On the head crab mama.
Oh, no.
If I blow him up...
He's just picking at something.
He's eating dirt.
Look at that.
Wow.
The game knows.
Game 100% knows.
Okay.
I am gonna quick save here then.
Is it...
How do I like...
Just kind of roll it?
How do I just kind of roll the grenade?
Don't get me.
Don't...
Don't do it.
Right click.
Eh?
It's not working.
I think...
I'm just gonna ignore them.
Can I just go around them?
There's so many of them.
Yes?
Okay.
Let's just go around.
This is...
Are you okay, buddy?
Oh!
Where do I go to?
I have to go up.
So...
Nope.
Mmm...
Over the ledge?
Once again, mysterious planes.
You don't hear anything.
You don't...
You don't sense anything.
I made it home alive!
Kairos!
Welcome home.
Oh, Kairi!
Half-Life does have an oddly satisfying sound effects to listen to on the drive.
I have to make it over the ledge.
Like this one?
Oh!
I see, I see.
Okay.
I went the wrong way.
From grenades and up.
Yup, yup, yup.
I see it.
Keep digging.
They remind me of birds.
They remind me of like...
45.
You didn't hear that, right?
Okay, we're fine.
Maybe we're okay.
Oh, gosh.
There's a tree here.
All right.
Onwards.
Onwards!
Okay!
Not bad!
Maybe?
What?
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Sorry, guys.
I just...
I just got out of the game somehow.
Okay.
Guys, I'm gonna go grab a drink real quick.
I'm out of tea.
So, I'm gonna go get that.
And...
Hold on.
Let's see.
Where are we?
Um...
Half...
We're on...
Uh...
Oh!
Wait, I think I just have this chapter?
And then the boss?
And then that's it, right?
Oh my gosh!
Woohoo!
Oh!
Yeah, I gotta stay hydrated.
Cause my...
My voice...
My throat has not been so good.
So I wanna make sure that I'm drinking lots of water and tea and stuff.
So...
Yeah!
I'll be right back!
Um...
Actually, do I have any?
Let's see.
I have no throat tea left, I think.
But I do have...
I do have some...
Some other stuff that I can use.
Okie dokie!
I think even next week...
I might take some more days off, you guys.
Cause I have so much I need to work on.
And it's all singing.
And I can't sing if my voice is not good.
So...
Nah...
I feel so bad about it.
What the heck?
Since in May I'll be taking a lot of days off, but...
But after May...
After May it'll be all good.
After...
May is just my really, really busy month.
And then after May I'll be mostly good, I think.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'll be fine.
Okay!
Okay, okay!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh, did I get a raid?
Thank you!
Thank you, whoever raided me.
Sorry, I went to go get some tea!
I did save, right?
I'll just save anyway.
Oh god.
What's here?
What's in here?
Oh, this is a bee man!
Shoot him in the butt.
Uh...
What do I want to use?
If I release the snarks...
Will it actually?
I don't think...
Oh...
I don't think that worked.
They turned on me!
Oh no!
That's so funny.
And terrifying and horrible at the same time.
Okay.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, I'm out!
Just kill me.
Just let me die.
Let me die.
Oh, I can just run past them.
Just let me die.
Just kill me.
Just kill me!
Yeah, I forgot to reload.
I forgot to reload!
Could I just run past them?
Do I even need to handle these guys?
You can try.
Just aim for the fleshy bits.
Like his arm?
His head?
Oh, damn!
That was smooth!
That actually ended up being so... not bad.
At all.
He didn't even notice!
I didn't need that, but it's nice to have.
Thank you very much.
What's this?
What was that?
Oh, more armor.
60%.
Okay.
We love you and would rather you take care of yourself than overwork yourself for us.
Please rest if you need to.
Stop it.
Thank you.
Only two bolts left, though.
I know.
I don't know what kind of final boss it is, so...
Whatever.
We'll see.
That's what I heard earlier!
That's what I heard, though!
I was like...
That's what I heard, and you guys said it was my suit going 15%.
No!
It was a...
It sounded like he's saying, You are not alone.
You are not alone.
That's what it sounded like he was saying.
Still sneaking.
I'm still sneaking.
I have five bullets.
That's it.
That's so sad.
What about this one?
Okay, we can reload this.
Oh, my God.
It's a whole society.
They live in a society.
Oh, come on.
You are not alone.
They live like... It looks like a little beehive.
I don't want them to notice me.
Oh, they're talking.
Oh, my God.
Baby.
Come, baby.
Mint, stop.
Oh, should I not have done that?
Oh, my gosh.
I finally get to see him.
Ew.
Omega My...
Oh, there he goes.
Peace is optional.
Wait.
Should I be... Should I...
Are they nice to me?
Oh.
There's more.
Not now.
Oh.
Should I not have killed their friends and family?
You're saying that's a bad idea?
Oh, God.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
Hello.
Oh, he's not killing me.
Oh, he's just a worker bee.
He's a worker bee.
Oh.
I think I messed up.
Oh, I think I messed up.
Yeah, I'm gonna kill you.
I'll kill the baby, though.
Oh, there's many of them.
There's multiple.
Uh...
How do I...
Redo!
Okay.
You alone, not you alone, not you alone.
Yeah, I'm not you alone.
That's not my name.
My name's MinPhantom.
Wow, I'm watching them work.
Look at them talking!
Oh, he's...
The work is too demanding!
That's what he says.
Okay, so I got a platform around here, I suppose?
Or, maybe not a platform.
Um...
But these don't seem like stairs.
Oh, wait!
Okay.
This is really...
This is triggering my trypophobia.
Oh!
Excuse me.
What's this?
Um...
Hold on.
Uh...
Maybe I need to go into there?
Let me look around, though.
This game kind of indirectly tells you here that...
The vortigons, zappy guys, are the slaves of the society forced to fight you under the control of the mine babies!
They're actually slaves to the babies!
To the bee men!
Oh, my God!
The bee men are made in a factory!
This game doesn't give you too much to tell.
They're friendly here, and eventually they aren't.
Oh, my God!
No!
The poor little bees!
I mean, not bees.
Those guys suck.
But these guys are just little worker bees!
Oh, no!
Wait a second, I'm making sure...
Okay, I'm gonna go into the zappy tap.
Excuse me.
It...
Does nothing.
Okay, cool.
Just a lowly alien trying to provide for my family!
Oh, it's a healing pod!
I see, I see it.
How do I get up there, then?
Let's stop...
Wait, does this go higher?
Oh, my God!
I see now.
I've learned the errors of my ways!
Uh...
Oh, please don't go...
Oh, he's so fru...
He's frustrated!
He's like...
I can't take it anymore!
Wait!
What did I do?
I mocked them.
Okay, let's...
Okay, restart.
Not you alone...
Oh, hello.
Thank you.
He also uses it.
It's so cute!
Oh, hello.
Wait, uh...
Here?
Oh, no, this is the...
This is the pod.
The healing pod.
What?
How do I get up there?
I think I'm stupid.
What...
Can I...
Jump to?
From here?
What?
Eh?
The other part?
Stand on the arm?
Oh, I guess we could try that.
I thought about that, but I thought this would also go high enough.
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
And then...
Okay, okay.
No, no!
No, no, don't go!
Don't turn evil, please!
Mister, mister, mister!
This isn't...
This isn't like you!
Oh, my God!
Holy cow!
Okay.
Um...
I'm...
I'm going in!
I don't know what's in, but I'm going in.
Oh, no.
It's a drop.
Uh, maybe I shouldn't go in.
Wait, what's down there?
My goop, or...?
Do I go into the goop?
They're just into...
Oh!
I have such fragile...
My bones are made of...
Of paper!
Or glass!
And my skin is made of paper!
Saddest moments of all time.
I don't know which one to go...
I guess...
I can't tell which one is...
The...
Appropriate one to go into.
So we'll just...
I guess I'll go down...
The goop chute.
Okay.
Alright!
Are the...
Are the bee men in this?
Are they...
Is this what the bee men are?
Yes!
Oh!
I don't think this was a good idea.
Oh goodness!
Oh gosh!
I don't wanna hurt you anymore!
But I will!
Oh!
Ouch!
Fine then!
Asshole!
Oh!
There's a baby too!
Holy cow!
I can't see them from so far away!
I'm trying to snipe them!
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Luba, thank you so much for the...
Ah!
Super!
I took a lot of damage there.
Shoot!
Oh my god!
Oh, I'm gonna die here probably.
No!
There's so many babies!
And so many...
So many electric guys!
Woo!
Oh gosh!
Hope you're liking the game!
I love Half-Life 1 and it's expansions.
I replayed it recently.
Using Svenkoop with friends.
I don't know what that is, but...
No!
Ah!
It loaded so...
I thought that it had...
Like it loaded into that area, so I thought it had saved.
Aw, that sucks.
Aw, man.
I thought the goop was a save!
Yeah, me too!
It's a G mod for Half-Life.
I see.
Co-op client.
Ah, okay, okay.
Does this game not usually have co-op?
I thought it did.
Okay!
I'm gonna save here.
Maybe I want to go into this room instead.
But...
Maybe I want to go this way.
I don't know.
Let's...
Let's change it up a little.
Oh!
We're going up?
I'm not going up.
I'm gonna get crushed.
Uh...
Don't mind me.
Okay.
We're going into the goop chute.
Why does he say that every time I reload in?
It's so creepy!
Okay.
Alright.
I shot him in the back.
I'm sorry, mister!
I'm sorry!
Okay, I'm gonna get these guys...
First?
Oh my god.
I didn't see him up there.
Stupid.
Stupid baby.
Yeah.
Fall into the goop.
Baby alien.
Man.
I could've sworn there was a guy here.
Do I jump using these?
No.
Please say no.
Please say no!
I'm gonna save.
Okay.
Oop!
Ouch!
Did that really hurt me?
Oh my god!
Ah!
Please!
Oh god.
Baby.
Baby, baby!
No!
I know, I hate these guys.
They're so awful.
Look at that.
They're all teaming up.
They're all talking together.
They're all talking.
They're scheming.
Oh my gosh.
Stop running.
Stop running and scheming.
Stop running!
What's up?
Do you guys know that...
There's like a...
A video of...
Of like a...
It's like a professor in...
A class.
And I guess it's like during when you know...
What like people...
Oh shoot!
I didn't realize that I was gonna get hit.
When...
Uh...
Classes were taught online and stuff.
And...
And there's one where the...
The professor's like...
Do you have any questions?
And this person has this like...
Alien voice mod on.
And it goes...
Blap blap.
Blap blap blap.
That's what the voice...
I'm hearing...
Sounds like.
I've wasted so many bullets.
I'm gonna have to redo this part.
It's okay.
Honestly.
Oh my gosh.
Baby!
Oh, there's a healing pod down there.
But honestly, I'm not concerned about my health...
As much as I am about...
My bullets.
My bu...
Oh no!
What did he cause a...
Okay.
I thought he caused a disrup...
Disruption in the...
In the flow of the...
How do we get down here though?
Um...
Can I just jump?
Uh...
Save?
Yeah, I'll make a new save.
So that...
This area sucks, but it's the last stretch.
Yeah!
That's the...
Oh, what is that?
Okay.
Bubble?
Where?
Where are you?
Is that a guy?
Oh my god!
Friend!
What is this?
Nothing?
Okay.
Save.
Save on the save one.
Alright.
Huh.
Uh...
Okay.
You son of a gun!
Yeah!
Let's see...
Do I...
I guess...
How do I get back upstairs?
Um...
That's the better question.
How do I get back up...
Is it this?
Is this like a little elevator?
Oh-ho!
I knew!
I was like, it's a different color...
For a reason...
Okay.
Alright.
Just don't open any of the containers.
I wasn't planning on it!
Okay.
Another one?
Where'd you come from, baby?
Yeah.
Where'd you come from?
I sound like I'm hitting on him.
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh no.
No, no, no.
Oh my god.
Ouch!
At least there's...
Towers in this to...
To hide behind and stuff.
I'm hitting on him.
Where'd you come from, baby?
Yeah.
Okay.
I think...
Where's he coming from?
Where?
I can't...
I can't tell.
Up there?
Oh yeah.
Oh, dang it.
It's fine.
Just leave him alone.
Oh, this goes down.
Okay.
Golly.
I can't remember.
What did we say that they sounded like they were saying?
It doesn't sound like it anymore to me.
I can't remember.
It was like something's really silly.
The guys.
Oh yeah.
Booty shot.
That's what it sounded like.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Booty shot.
I hear it now.
I hear it again.
Booty shot.
Oh, uh oh.
Okay.
I'm in trouble now.
Okay, let's...
Oh, I'm in real trouble now.
Oh, boop boop boop boop boop boop boop boop boop.
Oh my God.
Let me aim.
For your big ol' head.
And we're out.
Okay.
Uh...
The bees don't use ammo.
Do they attack the guys?
I can't remember.
Booty shot.
Oh, I hear them.
Yeah, they are getting hurt.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna...
I will save here.
I will click save.
It's fine.
Wait, maybe if I...
Did it kill him?
Oh, I guess it did.
Okay, cool.
Booty shot.
What's all this?
It's not ammo that I need.
Ammo I need here?
I wish I could move this.
Wait, there's like something behind here.
It's like a...
Wait, what's over there?
What's that over there?
This is all secret passage.
Don't break any of the barrels.
Break the barrels.
Got him.
I could, uh...
Let's see.
Hold on.
Let's do this.
And then...
I'll put a second one.
Oh, whatever was in there also got exploded.
Never mind.
He didn't get exploded.
Booty shot.
You blew up more than one?
I did?
No way.
Are we in trouble?
Oh, we did, but...
Oh, I see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It exploded a different one too.
Ah.
What is in here anyway?
Better be good.
It's just a shortcut.
Yeah, it's just a...
It's just a...
Um...
For everybody who's curious of the like-minded curious community such as me.
I just...
I just answered your question.
I solved all your questions.
Oh!
I don't need health.
I think there's a guy like right behind this.
Actually, since I'm getting so close to them, might as well use...
Oh, no?
Maybe not.
Okay.
It's giving us a lot of health and stuff.
Thank you, Minto.
You are so...
Welcome.
Um...
Holy cow.
No!
Booty shot!
Yeah!
Take that!
And we're getting more stuff here.
Oh, that's a bunch of C4.
Uh...
Surely they gave us...
Um...
Nope.
Surely they...
Uh, nope.
Anything that I used, they didn't give us a single thing of.
That's okay.
That's fine.
Probably.
SMG grenades?
Oh!
That's good.
That's actually pretty big.
Wait, hold on.
Okay.
Oh!
I didn't even notice you up there.
Time to use...
More C4.
Uh...
Can you come down, please?
Can you come down?
Oh!
Oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi, oi.
Please?
Okay, I got him.
Oh no!
I have to destroy this, don't I?
Oh, shoot.
Time to leave, like, five C4s.
You've been my travel buddy since I went out at 11 a.m.?
Welcome home!
Oh, no.
No!
You can jump on it.
I'm trying.
Oh, I did it!
I'm a gamer.
I'm a gamer!
Okay, cool.
Oh, reload.
Your Honor, shoot a game.
Oh.
Okay.
Someone is, like, for real having a crazy conversation in here.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, shoot!
Let's, uh...
I had to double check if I was pressing load or save.
This looks like doom now.
I know, right?
It really does.
It feels like doom.
Let's do the bees instead.
Yeah, let's do the bees instead.
Oh!
Oh.
That didn't work out so well for me.
Okay, I think I have to take care of the...
the electric guys first.
I need to take out the electric guys first.
And then...
But, like, make sure I don't...
Yeah, do that.
Okay, there we go.
And...
And then...
Then bees.
I think I got one.
No?
Just kidding.
Please die.
Oh, my God.
Yes!
Oh!
That
just grazed me!
Oh, my God!
It did so much damage!
It grazed me!
I wonder if I should have...
I wonder if I should try again.
My friend.
My pal.
What is this?
Wait.
Oh, but there's a healing thing.
Nah, we're fine.
We got the healing thing.
I have no armor anyway.
I don't think.
The bee gun does have alt fire, but it is not the homing bees.
It's like the...
The bees.
They...
I had, like, 30?
We'll see.
Barely none, yeah.
Okay.
I wish there was some health in here.
But, alas.
We must crawl into...
This red hole.
I'm gonna...
I'll make a new save.
Oh.
Oh, I don't like that.
Okay.
Where are they?
Booty shot.
I hear them.
The fun continues.
Of course.
Maybe they're in the walls.
They're in the walls.
Okay.
Alright.
Uh.
Pick your poison.
I guess they go to the same...
Why do they make things like this?
No, I'm in the walls.
Hahaha.
It goes to the same place.
Why do they have two openings, then?
Drop my...
Wait.
I don't think the bugs will work, though.
I don't think the bugs will work.
They...
They don't attack the people...
In here, do they?
They don't attack the guys in here, right?
The snarks will not work, you know.
Unfortunately.
Only humans.
The snarks always work.
What do you mean?
Hahaha.
Yeah.
They've never once let me down.
Oh, gosh.
There's so many...
I can hear everything.
It's...
It sounds...
Like it won't be good.
Hahaha.
It doesn't sound like it will be good.
I only have 50 ammo.
Good time to save.
I'll just save.
I'll save again.
Just...
Let's just drop down and see what the...
What the damage is.
I'm running, running, I'm running, running.
Oh, my God.
It really feels like doom right now.
Hahaha.
Feels like doom.
Like crazy.
Ouch!
Hahaha.
Feels like doom like crazy right now.
Can't you see?
Okay.
Can this heal any slower?
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Oops.
Oh, come on.
How about... Oh, I only have five left.
This might be a good place to use them, though.
Use them or lose them.
Maybe.
Bees?
Oh, okay.
Maybe bees.
I don't know.
Oh, we got a guy.
Yeah.
Booty shot.
Is he... Is he stuck down there, or... Get his butt.
Get his butt.
Come on.
Yeah, come on.
Get his butt.
Woo!
That was a crazy dodge.
Did he die?
I think so.
Um.
I heard someone up there.
He's quiet.
Oh!
Oh, please!
I think we did it, guys!
If we...
Oh.
Okay.
Booty shot.
Booty!
Here's someone else...
Come on, come... uh... There we go.
Oh, no!
There's still another baby!
Oh, the baby!
This is not good.
The baby's back, the baby's back, the baby's back, the baby's back, the baby's...
The baby's back, the baby's... Okay.
I don't think I should be using this weapon anymore.
Um... Oh my god.
I'm almost dead.
This is pretty bad.
Sniping with my... with my... with my... oh my god.
With my shotgun.
Ouch!
That's it.
This is it for me, guys!
Why are there so many babies?!
Oh my god!
There's so many babies!
I'm gonna go try to get to the other side.
That was less than ideal.
Try the... grenade launcher.
I was trying to save all my big boys for... the final fight.
Cause I don't know what kind of fight it is.
So I'm trying to save all my big stuff for...
I don't even have any... I don't have revolver bullets...
Oh wait, I got more!
When did that happen?
Mankey, mankey, mankey, mankey, mankey, mankey, mankey, mankey, mankey...
Sunset!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Happy, kinky, mankey.
It's slow and dumb, you should be good, they'll restock you.
Okay, okay, okay!
At least I say so.
I'm looking around real quick.
I think I got his ass for real this time.
I think I got that... oh.
Please, hold the door!
Would you hold the door for me?
Whoa, what is that up there?
This thing is... this thing is... woof.
Ouch!
I just got up here, please!
Okay, I'm running.
Uh-oh, they're coming?
Okay.
I'm back in the walls.
Oh, where the heck am I?
Oh my god.
Oh, this is literal hell.
Um...
Uh... I'm trying to see if I see any guys, but I don't.
I hear them.
Oh, there you are.
He's hoarding all the supplies!
Uh...
You gotta share...
Where?
Oh, there he is.
Yeah, good luck doing your job when you're dead.
Bozo.
Maybe I should have gone through the other one.
Is there anything down here?
Maybe I should have gone through...
Oh, wait.
It's a bunch of...
There's some health.
That's huge!
Let's go.
You've become my second Kamiyoshi.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Where?
This room is so scary because...
We're just gonna ignore the Hellcores?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Ain't...
Ain't no big deal.
Okay, let's go through the other one and then we'll be able to get the other stuff.
Dang, I thought this was the way out.
Or like the way we were supposed to go.
But clearly...
Not.
Alright.
All the babies are out here.
Nice.
Can't aim, little baby?
You don't have any functions yet?
Look, he's doing a jig.
He's dancing.
I have to go to the other side.
Why did the minky...
cross the road?
I heard another guy in here.
Somewhere.
I can't pick any of this up either?
Surely.
Surely game.
You...
You will give me some revolver ammo.
Surely.
Save.
Yeah, that's a good idea.
I keep making new saves because I'm not committed.
But I should be.
Because...
We've gotten this far already.
Oh my god.
Holy cow.
If I hadn't saved!
Should be good to quicksave.
Probably at this point.
Probably at this point, it's good to...
I can quicksave.
But...
I don't know.
I'm not committed.
Anything else?
No?
What's up here?
None!
Thank you for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
There's a hole there, Minky.
Wait, where's a hole?
Oh my gosh.
I had to be very careful about where I...
How I shot that.
My friend!
Oh my gosh, where the hell did you come from?
We got two bullets left.
I will quicksave.
Did we get crossbow ammo?
No way.
Wait.
Only five.
Save's coming.
Always.
Absolutely.
In games like these, I feel like it's encouraged.
I feel like it wouldn't be encouraged...
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
I feel like...
Aw man, all my armor.
I feel like a game, if they do quick saves and quick loads, that's encouraging saves coming.
That's my philosophy.
We gotta go up.
No!
Leave me alone!
Come on!
Oh, are you kidding me?
Never mind.
We did need to go up.
Uh...
Wait.
Is there another...
Oh, there's even more up.
Okay, we gotta go up, up, up.
Oh my god, there's so many babies again!
No!
Oh god!
Okay, okay, okay.
You know what?
Screw it.
You can ignore most of them.
Yeah, I'm going to try.
Up, up, and away!
Me!
Oh, we made it!
I am the last.
Last, I am the last.
This time?
Mates don't get tired, they get sleepy.
Sweepy.
I don't know where to go.
Hello.
Is this it?
This is it?
This is the boss!
The final boss!
Get the big boy out.
Oh, it did let me quicksave.
I thought it didn't let me quicksave for a second.
Alright.
Let's go!
Wait, what did I just...
I just heard someone speak.
Oh.
Oh my god, it's a big baby!
Oh no!
Giant baby!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
You're spinning!
Um...
Right.
Oh.
What is that thing?
Do I need to destroy that?
Shoot the crystal, yeah.
I discovered that afterwards.
It's like the ender dragon.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Oh!
Woo!
Ugh.
Please.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh.
No.
Oh no.
I'm just gonna reload.
Okay.
Anyway.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Let's just, uh...
Let's try that again.
And then...
Like, you hear it?
I hear someone speaking.
Oh, it's...
Oh, the scientists!
They're like, thank god you're here!
Oh my god!
It's the scientists!
Whoa!
That's cool!
The roomie teleports you to have his arm...
Ammo and...
Oh.
Wait!
Oh, there we go.
That's...
That was weird.
You know what I mean?
Run!
I don't wanna get teleported!
Okay.
Please, little baby.
Oh my gosh.
Ow!
Is it just you, little baby?
Where are you?
Where'd you go?
Oh, you're so small.
You're just a baby.
Oh my gosh.
I think I killed him.
Please, let me onto the platform.
Okay.
Is another guy coming in?
Nice.
Oh, what are those?
What is that?
Is that a baby?
They're babies.
Please.
I'm reloading.
It's like the Titanic movie.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's a matter, baby.
What's the matter, baby?
Okay.
Everything's a matter.
Including platforming in your, in the final boss fight.
And it's, I'm not even fighting the boss right now.
I'm just, I'm fighting his kids.
Which are also baby.
He's a baby.
His kids are babies.
Everything's a baby.
I don't know which one.
Everything looks the same too, so I can't tell where I need to go.
Everything looks the same.
We're babies.
Like, can I just like, I can't tell what is a platform.
Sometimes.
I think that's...
I can't tell.
These textures are horrible!
Jump to the left.
This one?
This?
Okay.
There is more...
Stuff here.
Oh, there's a baby.
Killed that guy.
Alright, um...
I feel like I'm in Junji Ito world right now.
For real.
Oh, no, please.
Oh, god, thank you.
Attack of the trypophobia.
Right!
No, no, no, no!
Okay.
Quick save?
So true.
You guys are so smart.
Thank you.
I didn't think about it.
I didn't think you could quick save in a boss fight.
Save often here.
I didn't even...
That didn't even occur to me!
Note the broken shackles on the...
On the wrists.
Not a strategy hint.
Just implied lore.
Mmm.
Why am I so bad at jumping less?
You can do it.
Normal?
I don't think so.
I'm so bad at this.
Stand right next to it and jump up.
Oh.
Oh, I see.
Octopath.
Wait, sorry.
I can't read your super turbo now.
I went so fast!
Oh!
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
But thank you!
Oh, my god.
Leave me alone.
I don't want to talk to you.
What is this thing right here?
What am I picking up that...
That thing?
I can't tell what it does.
Oh.
Good thing I said it.
Ammo serv...
Oh, it's a random ammo.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Almost there.
Isn't this so great, guys?
Almost there!
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Gordon Freeman is so... this guy is so... fast.
Booty shot.
Oh, I forgot to save once I got up there.
Okay.
Save.
Okay, cool.
Oh, I should have changed my weapon.
Oh, no, now the babies are here?
Say it ain't so.
What the?
Okay.
Oh.
What the hell is this?
What am I?
Where am I?
What is going on?
The truth.
You can never know.
There's so many babies.
What do I... What do I kill?
The babies?
One baby.
Oh, I'm out.
Reload, please.
Oh, my God.
You're on the ground.
Get up.
You lazy.
How do I... Oh, I have to platform, like, these little bubbles?
Are you kidding me?
Please reload.
This is the worst room.
SMG?
Do I just... just... just... take them out?
Like that?
Oh, my gosh.
I'm, like, stuck.
I'm... I'm actually stuck.
Okay, there we go.
I lost, like, everything.
Wait, do I have to platform these bubbles?
Oh.
Oh, it's not platforming, really.
Ah!
It didn't even touch me!
Uh-oh.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, what's in here?
Um...
Uh...
Booty shot!
Oh, my gosh.
Eugh!
He will deceive you.
Ugh, I took so much damage there.
Oh, my God.
This guy's...
Oh, my gosh!
Take cover if you don't want to be teleported.
Is that how that works?
Like this?
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Holy cow!
About to die.
I think I got rid of all the crystals.
Using dead energy.
I think?
Oh.
Oh, my God.
That's awkward.
Boop!
I can't tell.
He has a weak spot.
Ouch!
It's, uh...
Uh, I go up through these, right?
Yeah, because, like, see, there's, like, glowing light over there.
I'm trying to figure out.
Oh.
I'm just in here.
Okay.
Wrong one.
Oh, my God.
It didn't go up high enough.
Ah!
Okay.
This weak spot is made.
I wish... I wish the battle would be over then.
You spooked me.
Okay.
I'm hoping to get some health and stuff in here.
Uh... somewhere, maybe.
We barely... oh, wait, wait, wait.
There is stuff in here.
There's the fishy monster!
Oh, oh, oh, oh god.
It puts me in, like, such an awkward position.
Ouchy, ouch!
Oh my god, where did you show up?
Where the hell did you come from?
Oh my god.
Oh...
Okay.
I'm gonna try and get to the top of the head.
Let me see if I can...
From here.
Oh no, no, no!
It's not tall enough!
Oh...
Maybe...
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no!
Oh!
No, please!
I'm not jumping on top of it!
Oh...
Oh, it does...
I see what random stuff it gives you.
Oh, that's pretty nice, actually.
Oh, there he is.
These areas are so pain.
Oh my god.
It doesn't help that it, like, kind of puts me in a bad area when I, um...
load in.
In fact, I'll just save right here.
Okay.
This is better.
This is a better save.
Than being out in the open.
Okay.
Um...
Alright.
Let's see...
Let's go this way.
Hang on!
No, no, no!
Wait, maybe I can make it!
Maybe I can make it!
Oh my god!
I made it!
Where he gets higher?
I didn't think he would still get me, but...
Boink!
I can hide behind the pillar when he shoots the thing.
Okay.
Go, go, go!
Into the health pool!
Alright, alright, alright.
Um...
Hide behind the pillar?
No!
Please!
Hahaha!
Okay, okay.
I had it too.
I know I did!
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Go, go, go!
Down, go, down, go, down, go, down, go, down.
I'm gonna...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, gosh.
Please don't.
Please.
Mr. Please.
Please, Mr. Please.
No!
I'm doing my best over here.
And... whoop!
Uh-oh, I think that's the teleporter.
Yes, indeed it is.
Please.
No, you don't see me.
Redo.
We're gonna get this perfect.
Okay.
Okay, save.
Alright, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Okay!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I just don't... wait.
I just don't know how to get from...
What?!
From here, all the way over...
Do you see any other platforms?
Okay, sit...
I'm sitting in here?
Oh.
Hello, mister.
I'm sniping you with my...
Ouchie!
Oh, golly.
Wait.
Someone said I can shoot the portals...
To get rid of them.
Let's try it.
Oh, god.
Okay.
Okay, this is...
Here, I'm gonna try.
Oh.
I don't know if that was this, or...
Oh!
It does work.
Okay, okay.
Let's see.
Gonna bees them?
Bees!
This is not a good spot.
But I don't know how I can...
Get all the way to the other side from this...
From the jump.
Mmm...
Gotta jump to the left using the pad.
Oh, god.
You don't have to get to the other side.
I don't.
Oh, I don't know, actually, if it's the portal or not.
No, no, no, no!
I was pressing left like my life depended on it.
Which it... which it did.
But, um...
Okay, I'm just gonna go back to...
Throwing grenades.
Oh, no, see?
It doesn't always...
I really don't like this room.
I really...
I wasn't ready for this room!
I really don't like this room!
Don't make me come into here, please!
Oh, my god.
Don't make me be in the water.
Don't make me fight the guys.
Please!
This is my least favorite of the room so far!
Because it's so dark.
And I don't like the electric guys.
I'm just gonna turn my lights on.
Oh, I shot your dead friend!
Okay, don't go into the water.
The water's not worth it.
Something else just spawned, I think.
Ouch!
Ugh!
Sippy the water!
I'm struggling here.
I'll save once we get full health and the armor.
Deep breath.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it's just because I'm...
I was focused on people telling me to get on his head or something.
But I think I'm just gonna shoot at him.
I think I'm just gonna shoot at him.
No, you don't need to go up yet.
Oh, see.
That's where I was making the mistakes.
I think people just get so...
What's the word?
They get so excited.
Like, you know, they're like, Oh, you need to get up there so you can take it out!
But it's...
But it's not the case just yet, you know?
People get a little too excited and tell me info too quickly.
Yeah, a little worked up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a good way to put it.
Okay, so I'm guessing it's this nipple.
Beam me up, nipple.
I don't want to go into the water.
I'm trying to avoid the water.
Ouch.
Did you save?
Yes?
I did, right?
I wanted to be full health.
Oh, God.
I'm going into the water!
And then I'm gonna get right out.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
This is a good place to save.
Okay, okay.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's try the other one.
Rog pad.
Maybe.
And...
Whoop!
Oh, I should have gotten my...
Big guns ready.
Oh, gosh.
He still got me.
No!
You may now die.
Is that what you...
Oh, no!
Oh!
I am about to die, huh?
Look at him doing a little jab over there.
It's okay, we can load.
And what I'll do is I'm gonna get this gun out.
Reload it.
We're gonna... take out the guy who's doing the zappies.
Oh wait, let me save on the other side.
We'll take on... take out the guy doing the zappies.
Yeah, I know you can cancel the portals.
I... just... I... didn't have a... chance to get behind anything.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, alright.
Guy that's doing the zappies.
Where are you at?
There you are.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Woo-wee-wee.
Woo-wee-wee-wee.
This is a nice big thick... um... wall.
Woo-we-wee-wee.
Booty Shot!
Where at?
Where at Booty Shot?
Oh, I think he's behind.
Okay, hold on.
Get that, get rid of that guy before he gets rid of me.
They don't call, that's why they don't call me revolver.
Yeah, eat that baby.
That's why they don't call me revolver.
Okay, we got a baby.
Was that a second baby?
Two babies down.
Oh my god, his head is open!
Oh, now I go up!
I see, I see!
Okay.
What is that noise?
What is that...
Oh, oh, it's the booty shot.
Ouch.
Oh no, uh...
I messed up.
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna reload.
One moment, please.
What the?
Oh no, I messed up.
No!
That's not what I'm about to do.
Hold on.
My bad.
Okay, excuse me.
There we go.
Okay.
All right, all right, all right.
Nope.
Oh, nope, nope.
Yes.
And exchange.
Okay.
Now, uh...
I wanna get him in the brains.
I wanna get his brains.
Uh...
Oh, here it is, here it is.
I was right next to it.
What am I getting electrocute?
Oh, never mind.
Uh...
It's this one?
It's this one, I think.
Uh...
Oh my god!
Oh!
Gee Man!
Awww!
Gordon Freeman in the flesh, or rather, in the hazard suit, I took the liberty of believing you of your weapons.
Most of them were government property.
As for the suit, I think you've earned it.
I have a suit?
Oh!
The border world, Zen, is in our control.
For the time being, thanks to you.
Quite a nasty piece of work you managed over there.
You used me!
Oh, I can walk around.
What if I fall down here?
Mr. Freeman, I have recommended your services to my employers.
And they have authorized me to offer you a job.
They agree with me that you have limitless potential.
Limitless potential.
Easy toros!
Thank you so much for the take of the Deku!
You've proved yourself a decisive man, so I don't expect you'll have any trouble deciding what to do.
If you're interested, just step into the portal and I will take that as a yes.
I did save, guys.
Don't worry.
I saved.
Otherwise, well...
I can offer you a battle you have no chance of winning.
Save here.
Instead?
Ok.
Thank you so much.
Thank you!
Time to choose.
What?
What am I choosing?
What do you want me to do?
It's time to choose.
Oh.
Time to choose?
Well, it looks like we won't be working together.
Oh.
No regrets, Mr. Freeman.
Ooh!
Declined offer of employment.
Valve is...
Mito.
Now go through the portal.
Okay, let's skip the...
Let's load my quicksave.
Endgame.
Oh, my game is glitched.
My game is glitched.
It's kind of epic, but it's kind of awesome.
Woohoo!
Wisely done, Mr. Freeman.
I will see you up ahead.
Oh, then it started over again.
Yay!
Awaiting assignment.
We beat it!
I
was thinking with the baby, when everybody was saying that he had a weak point on his head, I was thinking that it was going to be like a little bitty hole at the top of his head.
And that's why I had to get up there, you know?
Ay!
Thank you for the big nipples!
Thank you!
Half-Life can be seen how cranky and mean sometimes, but she's got a unique charm.
True.
GG, nice run.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Mito gaming!
Yeah!
Well done, Miss Rantome.
Thank you!
Congratulations on beating Half-Life!
This is one of those games that just sticks with you after a while.
I can't wait to see you not rage at Half-Life 2!
It's honestly better!
Oh!
I thought you were being sarcastic for a second.
Please no spamming!
Thank you though!
It's a lot smoother.
Yeah, I'm excited for... I don't know if I'll do the...
If I'll do...
Um...
The DLC?
Or like the...
I guess it's considered DLC for this game before Half-Life 2?
Or what?
Oh...
I don't know yet.
Wow, Frank D!
Thank you so much!
Congrats, being a certified gamer!
Woohoo!
Yay, thank you!
Please do...
Please do take any breaks needed to heal.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Ah...
Don't forget all the thousands of mods.
Oh!
This was such a fun game though.
I'm still...
Like, what the heck?
I hope we get more...
More explanations, I suppose, in Half-Life 2.
Um...
The ending bit was...
I think that...
It was...
It was the...
Chapter before...
It was one...
The one that I was like sneaking around.
From the...
From the claw guys.
In the...
Like, in the last...
In Zen or whatever.
That one, I think, was the one that confused me the most.
Because it felt...
I don't know.
I felt like I was...
Was not going the right way like 50% of the time.
I was like...
Huh?
But, um...
I would like to see how everything looks.
Huh?
Sorry.
N is done in Black Mesa.
Uh...
So...
Will you play Blue Shift and Opposing Forces?
Probably.
I'd like to go through...
Oh...
Just heard something.
Sounded like someone fell outside.
Um...
I would like to go through...
The...
The series.
So...
Hmm...
But it was really cool to finally...
Play a classic like this.
You know?
Finally, I understand.
Well, I don't understand.
But finally, I'm like...
Oh, head crab.
Yeah, I know.
I...
I fought those now.
You know?
It feels so much better...
When you...
When you finally understand...
Like...
What things are from.
And...
Okay, what you mean?
Yeah!
I have the experience!
I killed the baby!
Woo!
Now it's time to host some multiplayer lobbies.
What is multiplayer like in this game?
Is it just the whole game?
But...
In multiplayer?
How?
Half-Life 2 adds way more story...
Is way more story heavy.
Adds some context.
Cool, cool, cool, cool.
Oh, it's deathmatch!
I think I...
Actually, I remember you guys telling me that.
If I hosted one and you guys joined, would you let me win?
I know you wouldn't.
No!
PvP deathmatch.
It's...
Half-Life Fortnite.
No.
I knew it.
Oh, I can't sell me out of here.
Ah!
Nah!
After...
After I started actually attacking the baby...
Instead of trying to get on top of its head...
It was so easy.
After I started actually attacking the baby...
It wasn't even that bad.
It wasn't...
Ha ha ha!
She said it was...
Easy.
Easy, baby!
Ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
Yup!
Ha ha ha!
I didn't say easy.
I said it wasn't bad.
Anyone else remember the G-Man squad series?
I don't know that.
Ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
The first part of that boss is the platform.
I tried to follow everybody's advice.
I should actually just shoot.
I'm never gonna follow advice again.
I'm a free... I'm minty free woman!
Good.
Never trust wisps.
Yeah!
Yeah, free woman.
Freeman?
Gordon Freeman?
Who?
Minty... Did I say minty?
Minky free woman.
Yeah!
But thank you guys!
I will probably go eat some dinner now.
She's gonna ignore us!
Now you understand why this game is a classic.
I know.
I do.
There were a lot of parts where I felt like I was really...
It's funny because the game feels so linear and then not at the same time.
And I was like, am I going the right way?
Like, so many times.
I was like, I feel like I'm not going where I need to go.
Blue shift is about two to three hours.
Opposing force is about two...
Two regular streams.
Or one long one.
Oh, okay.
Good to know.
Mm-mm.
So...
You did great.
Sorry for any strange pieces of help.
No!
I under...
I, you know...
I think it's...
You know, when I'm in mid-battle, my...
My anxiety is high.
So...
I might...
Come off as like a...
Blah!
But...
I understand that people are just trying to help.
You know?
Now...
I get it.
Now you can watch the 20-minute speedrun.
Oh, yeah!
I can!
Of the game!
Yeah!
Mm.
So...
Mm-mm-mm-mm.
I'm also very passionate about this game.
Yeah!
It's one of those types of games, right?
But you guys were very helpful for a lot of it.
So thank you very much.
I really appreciate it.
Mm.
Yeah.
It's always...
I feel like...
I feel like I'm playing with like a...
You know?
Like a bigger...
Older brother who's like...
Who's played the games.
And it's just like...
Mint, you gotta do this!
And I'm like, okay!
You know?
So it's like...
So it's...
It's like...
I'm playing...
With people.
It's fun.
Little sister Minto.
He-he.
He-he-he.
Yeah.
But yeah!
So I'm gonna go eat.
Um...
I'm glad I started this earlier.
It ended up being five hours.
Huh!
Now you know the context for full life consequences mostly.
Wait!
Can I watch that again?
And like...
Understand it?
Or do I have to play Half-Life 2 first?
If you ever finish Half-Life 2 Episode 2, you will understand the struggle of the fans from back in 2007.
Uh-oh.
Like...
Like the...
How it's not...
Um...
Uh...
Finished?
Like how there's no three?
After two.
Okay, okay.
Oh, Lambda!
Thank you!
I think you should try playing Hunt Down the Freeman too, Minky.
It's a really great spin-off.
I heard Kojima also worked on this game.
What?
Hunt Down the Freeman.
I like it up.
Wait, don't.
Wait, no.
Don't.
Wait.
Oh, it's a joke.
Oh.
Don't.
It's a meme.
Oh.
She's...
I like that I...
I...
When I was typing it, I was not looking at chat.
And then I looked back to everyone being like...
Nooo.
In slow motion.
Here's a shorter version of what I super chat to you earlier.
There was a boss in Octopath 2.
Oh.
Thank you, Roka.
I'm so sorry.
No, I'm so sorry.
It felt like you had the super chat again.
I tried her again.
Oh.
A boss in Octopath 2 that you lost to.
I tried her again during your last stream and won this time.
Thank you, Miss Lucky Ghost.
Minto was baited by the Kojima mention.
I was like...
I didn't...
I didn't fully believe it.
Because I was like...
What did Kojima have...
At all to do with it?
You know?
But...
Yeah.
Silly.
Silly, silly, silly, silly.
Isn't terrible if you change to in-dev beta, but it's not official and not good.
Oh, well, I don't even know what it is.
Half-Life directed by Kojima though.
I feel like...
I almost feel like Death Stranding is as close as what you're gonna get to that.
I somehow feel like Death Stranding is...
Like the closest you'll get to a...
Half-Life directed by...
Kojima.
I highly recommend the documentary Valve release for the 20th anniversary.
Also, thank you for the gift sub.
Oh!
Thank you whoever gifted the sub.
I would like to watch that probably once I finish the games though.
Half-Life has no cut scenes though.
True?
True, true, true.
Oh my gosh.
Well, I can already see like...
Like the game...
Doesn't look like MGS1, but it's close enough.
You know where...
So during...
During some of the hallways I could see how like...
Kojima might frame it.
Or like...
How...
He would show off like the headcrabs...
Kind of like...
Down the hallways.
Or something like that.
You know?
It's a lot of environmental storytelling.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a fan mod that was overhyped and...
Under good.
Is the best way to describe it.
I see.
Are there any other classics you want to try out?
There's a lot of games I want to try out.
Hmm...
I still gotta start...
I still gotta start at...
Very beginning Ace Combat.
I don't know if we would consider that a classic.
But...
Uh...
I gotta do Death Stranding.
That's not a classic.
But I really want to do that.
Especially...
I don't think I'll be able to get in before Death Stranding 2, unfortunately.
But...
Halo!
Yes!
Would be great.
More Castlevania?
Yeah!
More Castlevania would be great.
Uh...
Portal 1 actually...
Does have lore relating to Half-Life.
Once you've played this...
Really?
Wait, that's so exciting!
Oh my gosh.
Now I'm gonna have to replay Portal.
If you're ever looking for a spooky game that's a classic...
You could try the Blair Witch Project.
A childhood?
Didn't they have a Blair Witch Project game?
Wasn't that just a couple years ago?
But also...
I...
A few years back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I...
Yeah, the one with the dog.
I won't ever play that game because of the dog.
Not to get into spoilers or anything.
But I feel like this is good to know.
If you do want to play this kind of game.
Because...
There's a scene...
In the Blair Witch Project where...
The dog gets hurt.
And like you're carrying him.
And he's just like...
He's just whimpering.
And...
I...
I won't...
I can't do it.
No, no.
I can't do that kind of stuff.
I guess...
I hate when horror hurts animals just for the shock factor.
It's so...
Mm-mm.
I...
I'm really, really against that.
Planning to play the Splinter Cell series.
Oh!
Ugh!
You know what?
In the past...
If you had asked me...
Like...
Three years ago.
Even two years ago.
If I would play Splinter Cell.
I would have told you no.
But now...
I might consider it.
Though I've heard it's much more difficult.
So...
Hmm...
I've heard it's more difficult.
But...
I...
Am willing to try it.
Just to say that I've tried it.
You know what I mean?
Hahaha.
Not because I wanna be like...
Oh...
I love stealth games now.
I love Metal Gear.
I love stealth games.
But...
Just because I wanna be like...
Hmm...
I feel like...
As a Metal Gear fan...
People will say like...
Oh, you need to try Splinter Cell 2.
Or Splinter Cell as well.
And if I say...
Ah...
No.
But if I say...
Oh yeah, I tried it.
I didn't like it.
I can at least say that I tried it.
Hmm...
Max Payne.
Haha.
Since we're on a topic of recommendations.
I don't know how we got on this topic.
Haha.
Crypta FM.
I've never heard of that one either.
Thank you, DFT.
I've never heard of that actually.
Two games beaten in two days.
Three of you count Visage.
Yeah!
We're killing it!
You were very...
Literally distracted and derailed by a Splinter Cell meme on your...
May 3rd, 2024 stream.
Wait!
Exactly one year ago?
Really?
Wow.
I don't remember...
I think I vaguely remember the meme.
But I also don't remember it.
I remember seeing it.
I don't remember what it was.
If you do one split jump on Splinter Cell...
I'd say that's enough.
Haven't seen some VTubers stream Max Payne.
Wait.
What kind of game is Max Payne?
Is it FPS?
Third person.
Actually...
Speaking of third person shooter...
Mogu...
Mogu asked me...
She was just like...
Do you want to play?
She asked...
She invited me to...
It was like...
Oh gosh.
I can't remember what the other game was.
I think it was like...
Wow.
Let me just open up Discord.
Mogu...
Where are you?
There you are.
She asked if I wanted to play...
Split Fiction?
Or RE5?
And I was like...
Oh my gosh.
I've been wanting to get into Resident Evil.
So I was like...
Let's play Resident Evil 5, please!
So...
Probably...
It won't be until I...
Until the...
Until the end of...
Until I get back from my Japan trip.
So...
In June...
Sometime maybe...
We'll start it.
Or maybe later this month.
I don't know.
When I'm less busy.
Or...
No, I'm gonna be more busy...
Later this month.
I remember there was a time...
When the MGS series...
Is almost forgotten...
And Sam from Splinter Cell series...
Made a note to...
Yes!
I've seen that cutscene...
They're talking about...
Where he's just like...
I guess it's just me then.
Yeah!
I've seen that!
RE5 is peak goofy fun.
I wanna play it so bad.
Have you played the other RE games?
I've only played...
And this is so bad.
I've only...
Literally only played...
Resident Evil 1.
And that was...
I didn't beat it or anything.
It was...
When I was a kid...
And I was playing like...
Silent Hill...
And everything like that.
So...
Yeah.
Max Payne is technically...
The beginning of the Remedyverse...
Which includes control and...
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Gato!
I literally...
When you...
I just thought about Owl and Wake...
And I was like...
I wanna play those too!
There's so many games!
There's too many games to play!
Yay!
Oh!
I'm canceling all my...
Concerts.
I'm canceling them!
So I can play more games.
Just kidding.
Max Payne and the other Remedy games are amazing.
You'd love them.
Sam Lake is...
Finish Hideo Kojima.
Ask Maddie?
Okay, I will.
JK on this?
Nah...
Yeah.
RE2 is the best.
I...
I don't know if I should play the originals.
I really don't wanna play original...
Resident Evil.
But I'm like...
Do I play...
The remakes or the originals?
I don't know.
But...
I've heard...
Mixed about everything.
You should play the remakes.
The remakes are good.
Yeah.
Oh!
Lollipop Chainsaw!
Yeah.
I have not played it myself.
But I do know it.
No More Heroes?
I think I actually watched Maddie play No More Heroes.
Wait.
Was it No More Heroes?
No.
What's the one that curses a lot?
And has the...
The gun that...
It's another...
Grasshopper game.
It's like really raunchy.
Shadows of the Damned!
Was that it?
Let me check.
I think that's the one I watched.
Shadows of the Damned.
The...
Yes.
It got a re...
It got a remake recently.
For Killer7.
For those who don't know who I'm talking about.
Maddie.
She goes by Oh That's Raspberry on...
Twitter.
Maddie's a big Grasshopper fan.
She's a big Grasshopper fan.
And she...
Worked...
Works...
Worked for...
Grasshopper even.
So...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She...
She made it.
She was a fan who made it.
That's Shadows of the Damned.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But she's really...
She's really great.
She's one of my friends.
She does those MGS comics.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She's really great.
I love her.
She streams.
So...
Um...
If you ever wanna see some...
She does a lot of like...
Niche things too.
So...
If you ever...
Wanna watch someone play some like...
Niche video games.
I'm pitching...
I'm pitching her Twitch right now.
I love her so much.
She's a super sweetheart.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But um...
Mmm.
I actually told her how to make Snake barf on MGS3 when she streamed it.
No way!
Half-Life.
More like half my wife.
Anyway, Maddie's comics rule and we love you.
Enjoy the end of Gordon's adventure.
Wait, what do you mean end of Gordon's adventure?
I'm gonna play him again in 2, right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Thanks for the Half-Life stream.
Miss Free Woman.
Thank you, Kavu!
And Pirate.
I don't think yours is gonna get through all the other...
Super chats and everything.
So thank you, I see you.
Don't know.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
And thank you guys for the stream.
I'm gonna head out now.
I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go eat like I said I would before.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, it did make it through.
Look at that!
Yippee!
Guys!
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
Tomorrow is DMC5.
So...
I'll get some rest...
I gotta do my daily login so I can get a gorb.
A-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Bye bye!
Bye bye bye bye!